welcome ladies and gentlemen to the junior speed
chess championship brought to you by chess kid
i'm gm daniel naredinsky and it is my pleasure
to be commentating an amazing match today between
grandmasters arjun and omaraji bhukesh uh and an
honor to be commentating today with grand master
vidiq rafi uh one of uh top players in india how
are you doing are you as excited for this match as
i am i'm looking forward to it and more than that
i'm impressed with your pronunciation of the names
good job well i was practicing all morning i don't
want to disappoint you know i try to do my part
but i appreciate it uh well before we delve
into uh the games in just a couple of minutes
uh we wanted to remind you of a couple of
things first let's take a quick look at
the bracket as it currently stands yesterday
of course we saw nihal seren delivering a
scintillating performance against andrew
tang and advancing to the next stage
do any names sort of catch your eye do you predict
any sort of early favorites as you look at the
bracket yeah i think few names uh stand out
to me uh i think uh sarana is a good player
and i see asi pinko he it will be a very tough
match i think they both play against each other
i see uh perham who plays quite a lot online
i think he'll be one of the favorites i also
see martirosian there jeffrey chong so i think
these players really catch my attention i think
those are the players to look forward to i would
say agree completely and um we do have a sort of
statistical forecast a prediction that should
be taken with a grain of salt that prediction
says that nihal sarin will indeed be the winner
and he will defeat san sebian another blitz and
bullet juggernaut in the finals but once again
that is to be taken very much of the grain of
salt so many of these players uh can't think
in this prediction you know uh alexis sarana is
maybe the favorite against sam savion just saying
you know no i agree it's definitely a lot of x
factors here but speaking of predictions we have
our smarter chess match prediction for this match
today um and vidit it is giving an overwhelming
percentage uh probability percentage to arjun
eridaisu what do you have to say to that yeah i'm
surprised but not so surprised because as you said
you know earlier when we are speaking that arjuna
is really good in blitz and he's always there on
chess.com playing blitz and you have played a
couple of games with him i know gukesh better
than arjun so i know gokey she's a very creative
player and a fighter but i don't think his
skill set like his best skill set is blitz or the
faster time format so i think this prediction is
correct i don't agree with the percentage but uh
still arjun is like the big favorite i would say
well we will certainly be delving into
that uh further as we take a quick look
at the format and the time control uh just
to remind you we of course have 16 players
um and the time control is 90 minutes of five plus
one then a break followed by an hour of three plus
one another small break followed by 30 minutes
of bullet one plus one so one second increment
in all of the segments uh and we will
have that of course for the match
today as we gear up we will have liftoff
very very shortly um and uh as you mentioned
definitely i've seen arjun around playing so
much blitz i've played hundreds of games with him
he's definitely more experienced and the
ball is definitely in groucases court
i think should have better chances
in the five-minute portion compared
to the other uh time control i think
he has to really set the pace there
um otherwise if he gets down on uh the scorecard
i think it would be tough for him to come back
yeah we saw that yesterday with uh mihal sort
of setting the tone i mean it was even for most
of the five minute board and then at some point
the halls just took off so i agree i think when
you're the less experienced player you know with
the five minute portion it's a little bit closer
to classical chess uh so you have you know sort
of a little bit more leeway and you mentioned
vidit that you said is a very creative player so
maybe that extra time in the five minute portion
will be to his benefit and here we have liftoff
you can expect some kings indian from ghoukish
well we have right now uh arjun playing white
in the first game we have queens gambits we
had a lot of those yesterday actually and um a
catalan okay interesting dc a6 very trendy line
mm-hmm yeah completely not up to date with uh a
lot of the theory but looks like black is trying
to keep the pawn and yeah that's become sort of
fashionable hasn't it is not supposed to be the
main move like knight fd2 is supposed to be the
main move i played quinine to myself uh but if
black plays accurately he's more or less okay here
well here's up the point he's kept upon for sure
where is white's compensation coming from does
he go for knight c3 and uh not really i think
the idea is to uh play bishop b2 maybe sometimes
and bishop d695 those kind of ideas uh then you
exchange off you know the bishop and you get some
play or you can play like bishop d2 rook c1 and
knight e1 so the idea of bishop d2 is that you
don't allow knight to b4 and then it's kind of
awkward there aha so there's that tension and you
go for the c5 square that's a really interesting
so it seems like you can play this more
tactically you can play it more positionally
um but arjun taking his time here exactly he
seems a bit uh surprised wrong moment to think
if you're entering this line uh but i expect
bishop b2 seems much more natural than bishop d2
i agree it seems a little
bit less awkward um and uh
putting the pressure immediately it seems exactly
these lines where you i don't know giving
up a pawn for positional compensation and
blitz it can be difficult to prove stuff
when you have such limited time on your
clock but here we have 95 immediately i
really don't like this move so if you take
bishop b7 i think is the point rook b7 d e now
knight where should it go uh well it's actually
not so simple because knight d5 there's maybe
95 with the idea of putting it on b4 but then
um yeah night before you have rook d1 is what you
are oh well first of all after knight g5 i can ah
rook takes a6194 here yeah but then rugby
one right rover d1 yeah exactly black is nice
it's gonna be dangerous it doesn't feel like the
most uh appropriate way to play i agree can you
play knight before but then it's a concession
yeah knight if i played okay bishop b7 so i
guess we'll see maybe knight d7 but that
felt a little bit awkward to me knight b7
you could consider going rook t1 you
could consider taking on a6 and 965.
you know if the pawn is lost so white needs to
be very careful but maybe rook takes c6 is more
prudent let's see what so he's thinking arjun
is thinking after knight d7 this seems to be a
critical moment here in the early going to the
first game what do you think what do you expect
rook d1 or rook a6 i think rook a6 because if
knight takes e5 you can attack that knight let's
say this would be too that seems to be a little
bit less of a risky continuation yeah what do
you think yeah rook a6 seems good then maybe 95
bishop b2 uh bishop d6 that is f4 always right
oh yeah and then g7 potentially falls now queen d3
i thought but that leaves the eighth rank exposed
that's actually really the yeah okay it looked
nasty there i mean maybe but king e7 is there's
no way this can possibly survive i mean even an
end game doesn't seem particularly appetizing
so yeah so rook takes a6 to me at least looks
risk-free it looks natural um but there's
definitely something to be said for trying
to keep the c5 on very interesting like very
exciting game right away not like a boring opening
they're going for the board exactly both of them
um and i i i agree with you i like this approach
for boucase to try to put the pressure early
in the five minute portion um but obviously the
question of will it backfire we saw this yesterday
you know they're not afraid to spend a lot of time
in the first you know 50 moves trusting especially
the more experienced players like argent trusting
their abilities with seconds on the clock i missed
the match yesterday okay how dare you leave
the comments that's it completely unacceptable
completely unacceptable well it's a bit late in
india so that's why i don't want to hear about it
you've said all all i needed to hear so rookie one
in fact played now queen a8 is that what we were
thinking uh lucas might choose yeah right yeah and
let's say black just develops with maybe bishop
yeah yeah knight c3 i want to play knight
b5 for example yeah so knight b5 is a bran
maybe knight c5 oh knight b5 knight p3 there's
like rook takes a six ideas i would never take
knight b3 yeah like castle in the first yeah
yeah the first second you have yeah exactly so
bishop b7 that's what he's trying to do but that
creates its own problems with the knight on d7
um so rook takes a six here is he intending to
castle and does white have any way to potentially
exploit this knight maybe queen f3 aiming but
then there's like knight takes e5 ooh yeah
95 is a nice tactic by the way and the rook on
d1 hangs just for the crowd here if queen takes
b7 so a lot of really sharp tactics here and
not a lot of time anymore to consider it before
but rook a6 castle i will not be like upset
now with white like at least i got my pawn back
i'll play bishop b2 and i think it's better
for sure a little bit yes uh and then maybe
rook and swing over to c6 yeah maybe he's like
displayed somewhere in my opinion black misplayed
i don't know where but it definitely but why is
urgent so slow on the flip side i was going to
say two minutes to the good here for and there we
go rook takes but that seems such a natural move
and yeah definitely it seems like
bouquet has to castle here otherwise
there will be hell to pay after queen frequent c6
uh yeah yeah yeah he has to castle maybe queen c8
is an option i don't know uh but yeah i'm not
so happy with black's position to be honest
right once i dislike a position it's very hard
for me to like it back no i i completely agree
the pawn has been recovered and a lot of
positional pressure so bishop b2 is the
simple movement he's done and now has to unpin
it himself it would seem to me maybe queen to c8
at least try to liberate the knight get some sort
of leverage there and rook c6 maybe rook b6 giving
up another pawn on b5 yeah but then it's like
slightly tragic like you're just pointing around
yeah yeah you thought you would at least be upon
up and suffering now you're on down and suffering
oh my god rook c6 there we go but this rook
is like a splinter a knight v8 just doesn't
seem very appetizing even if you've got c5 in
that weakens d6 yeah also knight c5 sometimes
you have to be careful about some bishop a3 stunts
but right now it's not working because of b4 yeah
maybe just queen c2 for example right
and you're threatening to take the knight
so what's the current position okay this
is the life yeah this is the position
and this is a good move i like it good movie great
yeah just laying down the wood here and these
positions like if you solve one problem you know
it's like you open the door to four other problems
um and that goes for like if you play c5 you
weaken this d6 square and then white's nike head
there or knight f6 i mean there's a million things
awaiting black i have no idea what to do here
just develop jesus i think he'll play with him uh
he's still thinking he'll blow up trust me on it
i'm trusting a hundred percent rook d8
no but that's a mistake i think
quincy too you're absolutely right
and the knight has to go right yeah
yeah because it threatens with 65
yep yep knights mistake i think he can he felt the
pressure usually in five minutes if you think for
one minute on a move that means that something
is wrong at least on the board or in your mind
something is like just not right there because
you are like okay hesitating and you don't really
want to think for a minute right and usually
the pressure on the position makes you do that
yeah that's a terrible sign you're not satisfied
with anything and here i think has to accept the
inevitable keep that time advantage now after 97
it's definitely not losing yet white has to prove
exactly how he's going to make
progress he can triple on the c
file and i know i hate to say this but bishop d8
keeps things together fitted for the time being
but now maybe then i can just head
to like four or something like that
is this the light position the light position
is rook d bishop d4 okay so he's gone with d8 he
had some ideas of uh infiltrating to d1 but now
he has to go back to d7 now this one right yeah
is this like just lost i think it is because now
to see seven point falls and yeah but i think
you're the expert of surviving such positions i'm
the expert at dirty tricks lagging and the one
second increment it really as we've seen in the
early going of these matches it really changes
the dynamic a little bit um but not a ton you know
time scrambles are still time scrambles so i see
that uh aran hawaii was in the chat and he said
a while vidit has appeared i guess he's referring
to my hairstyle which is again not out of choice
but you know due to the pandemic everything is
closed oh yeah i know i can completely concur
upkeep is not easy uh but i think it looks good
now bishop before might be playing nah 94 yeah
yeah the knight oh but then we'll see seven i in
the rook indeed yeah i think we should not be
good good move bishop if it is good 94 anyway
is possible he decides to release the tension
now go knight e4 now the knight potentially gets
to be six seven seconds four windy five good move
yeah i love this time pressure part oh it's great
buckle buckle your seat belts guys don't forget we
need four going for the queen trade very practical
decision it seems to be by argent oh nice i think
black played the last couple of moves better than
white i agree yeah popping the queen back maybe
what would you do two seconds left yeah yeah yeah
h4 improving the position slowly queen bacteria
preparing knight c6 stopping it look at the
prophylaxis by um every thread seems to be by
origin yeah and he loses yeah that's the worst you
should never lose on time yeah that's like yeah
that's the worst now the position was of course
incredibly difficult but yeah i hate to be the
backseat driver but sometimes video you just
have to make a move you just have to make
a move yeah a big time score uh here by um
by origin good game by the way the victory very
good good game very controlled nice effort yeah
gurkish played well in the opening part
like opening face put some pressure but
somehow uh he couldn't sustain it and once
the pawn was gone i already felt a bit
uh you know i lost a bit of hope there
for black yeah it's just psychologically
very difficult to play those positions where
you've lost that one thing you've suffered for
and yeah we have a king's indian attack here
um now as this game is is still in its early
stages i think we can take this opportunity
with it i noticed that um recently you've been
participating in a really interesting project that
involves master classes by a lot of top players
and i thought that was really cool could
you perhaps tell us a little bit about
what you've been working on and what that project
involves as this game proceeds from the opening
to the middle game i mean uh right now you must
have seen that even during olympiad there was
like so much of interest and at the finals in
one of the streams there like 68 000 people
watching so there is like a certain chess boom in
india and many people are interested in the game
so which is very cool um and there's one company
called an academy which is like one of the biggest
education giants in india and now they are like
moving into chess which is like really awesome
because it could really lead to a lot of new
people playing chess which is of course very
nice and what they've done is they have decided
to make a platform it's an education platform so
all the top grand masters of india are
teaching there including me like there's anand
there's me and uh there might be even kramnik
joining in soon you know fingers crossed
so big players are there any actual strong
players in it like qualified instructors
that's awesome yeah they contacted robert hess
but he was too busy yeah so it's very nice so
every other day i'm giving a master class
and like basically taking through my journey
so anybody if uh is there from india and they want
to join it would be great uh it's an academy and
it's a discount for they have an early discount
right now so they can just use uh with it 94
there's a code and uh join in yeah it would
be great to get master classes from how do
you spell the academy is it a uh you said uh sorry
sorry sorry i'm speaking too fast an academy u n
and i'm going to type it into the chat you
and then academy yeah yeah yeah i like that
absolutely of course i mean that sounds like
an amazing project i'll check it out myself
and awesome to hear that you're participating
in that video it's it's so hardening to see
chess boom all across the world particularly in
india i've noticed a lot of gm's are doing some
incredible streams um instructional and playing
blitz and it's great to see so much engagement
um just very very heartwarming uh what else is
heartwarming i think is white's position here
now i never really know how to evaluate these
positions it looks really good for white but if
black just closes things up with f5 how extensive
do you think white's advantage is here did it um
i wouldn't say it's like a big advantage it's
just a game right uh i would my first idea is
to play like rook d1 and i want to play knight e2
and c4 like break through there um otherwise go g4
but yeah these two ideas come to my mind it's
too soon to say though yeah g4 i was thinking
maybe black can try something like take stakes and
h5 undermining g5 square i'm not really worried
yeah then you have this and then this uh yeah i
really like this i think to some people it might
seem like the weakness of f5 is significant but
really white uses it almost to his advantage um so
i think that's a great point he does play knight
e2 you really do know wow that's pretty and e3 so
implying that maybe he wants to play b4
and that is immediately stopped by argent
so again the question now for
lucas which side of the board
does he want to try to make progress
and centralizing his knight for now
definitely unpleasant did it here do you
like white do you like white positions i
love white well i have a particular fondness for
these kings indian structures yeah the idea of
g4 the more i look at it black could meet it
with g6 now i don't think black's position is
you know in danger of imminent collapse but your
idea of c4 i think is actually really really good
what's this also then there's like
a very cool idea bishop f2 bishop h4
going for those dark squares yeah at six you
so is he is he trying to play g5 does blackjack
work his straights and counter play i guess
so i mean otherwise what's the point but g4
g4 i would go for it right now right
this is a great opportunity because
yeah i guess black can go g6 now your idea bishop
f2 bishop h4 hunting down those dark squares in
the king side that looks very very nasty i mean
maybe now black takes me goes h5 but really
nothing has changed and then you know as nimsovich
told us one of the sort of founders of positional
chess you know you play on one side of the
board and then at the right moment you switch
to the other and that can have a devastating
effect for the player that's kind of cramped
um not that i've really ever read
my system from cover to cover that's
um i think nobody really read it it's like peer
pressure you know everybody says it's a great book
and then you just join in and say yeah yeah
it's great but nobody has really that exactly
i was gonna talk to you about that and get the
perspective of someone who's actually really
really uh good at chess and you know there is see
there seems to be this uh these set of books right
then game manual that all of the gm's like it's
unacceptable to be a gm and say that you haven't
read it except nobody really read more than a full
couple of patients yeah yeah yeah i agreed 100
it's really important it's just like one player
sees it and you're too afraid to contradict and
you say yeah it's a good book and we really don't
want i mean i'm not saying it's a bad book but
the point is uh nobody has read it page to page um
right i believe that nowadays it's better to like
just uh learn from your games and uh there are
very few books which really interest me anymore
i think this positional decision making by
girlfriend is like really cool i liked it
but most of the books are theoretical which
you can't really like you know go through
it's like a task i don't like that when
you have to read a book as if it's a task
right it has to be for enjoyment and nowadays
reading competes with so many other stimulating
activities it's just hard in general like you know
i like reading in general but it's been hard but
yeah this whole you know pressure of of reading
reminds me of my school days when i would
you know i'd get assigned a huge portion
of reading and i would only read the first
page but i would read it very carefully so
when the teacher would test the students
to see whether they had done the assigned
reading i would raise my hand and deliver
this elaborate analysis of the first couple
of sentences of course i did not read cast
though in any case now we have some developments
in the game that if arjun has castled long i kind
of like what he's doing here yeah yeah very
practical very practical he wants to go g5
so i was thinking maybe queen g3 g5 f5 but there
is bishop f6 is there i mean it's a bit messy
what was that avoiding the undefended queen you
love such stuff i mean you i i do tactics exactly
i do now take stakes i do like really like this
idea for black because even if white secures
the pawn with d4 and we have some developments
here without further ado we have b4 and totally
understandable the case trying to rip open that
queen side but arjun has time white does have the
eventual idea of breaking through but he has a
couple of tempi to whip things up maybe g5 in this
position has to be considered but i'm going to let
him do the calculation as i sit back and sip my
matcha green tea i love to watch other
people calculate that's the commentator's
job so how do you comment it when robert
is there he never calculates anything
but his intuition is legendary um you had to join
me you have to join me in the roast of robert
let me down there oh no i i trust me and i'm just
warming up i'll roast them like you've never seen
i'll roast them like you've
never seen um yeah g5 played wow
so obviously i like i want to play a 595 bishop
b6 like go white wow but there's knight f3
there's knight f3 attack counter attacking the
queen bishop c7 91 bishop dude what the hell is
going on totally okay let's see what happened
d4 has been played he's who's the pawn on e5 i
don't like boring h5 now looks pretty interesting
knight g5 hg just set things ablaze and then take
on g5 go bishop g6 but that's but okay this is a
little bit not very good maybe yeah this doesn't
look like black really has anything maybe he
does more harm than good but is it like a generic
russian accent or it's like someone specific
generic but okay i can try to do them no but i
try this way it's more like alexander grisham but
okay oh wow no but i appreciate it very much try
to do it as best i can but but i mean more that's
like vegan gaming this is more like rambunctious
but i mean okay i think you know this way
that way okay no but conceptually i think
bites would be weak but is white winning here
this is actually very messy and we're entering
the time pressure stage no no the fight is
not at all winning i think it's but okay
but what is transition i would take black i mean
any day go h5 next move and white hasn't made
anything happen on the queen side yeah yeah
maybe three so like h5 you meet with g5 but
still bishop b4 yeah it looks it looks bad and
now he's trying to get the oh look at bishop f5
nice and time pressure nine seconds to say
this is so much harder to play for white
looks like the wheels the roof has
come out here for cash bishop takes g4
uh oh this is about to get very ugly h5 here
is possible at the very least and he does it
b5 okay he's trying the best he can but black
sub just comes first bishop g5 with a four
he doesn't even care about he doesn't care
arjun is playing more consistent not necessarily
like the best moose but more consistent throughout
and in the last minutes gurkish is losing
control like d4 was a bit like too timid now
no i agree with zero man 2-0 rough rough start um
and you kind of called it uh it just you have the
sense of of a very experienced blitz player very
practical um and okay struggling in these critical
moments um as you said maybe playing a little
bit too conservatively yeah how do you do you
make these adjustments during the match is that
a thing you can do sorry not not to interrupt you
yeah no this line is very interesting because i've
played like five games with this knight d2 knight
c4 very hard practically for black if he doesn't
know because just for a pawn you get like huge
initiative uh even in the end game of course yeah
such positional control and knight d4 is already
a mistake after 92 b5 is supposed to be the
main move this is like you know bit ugly mm-hmm
this looks really nasty yeah yeah yeah and people
need to understand that even with the trade of
queens that doesn't mean black is doing okay
he's not yeah because this catalan bishop yeah
that's that's a monster it's just dominating
it's paralyzing the bishop on c8 and i think
bishop c5 maybe i have a feeling because he's
thinking so much what else can you do he took on
and f3 okay that does seem pretty reasonable i
think but queen beat three and rook d1 or wait
wait how would you go about this that does look
pretty good actually um what else can well bishop
g5 maybe also um not such a big fan of bishop
g5 because i don't know what's the thread there
i was thinking bishop takes up six also with
it you're not supposed to criticize i only 2700
plus players can criticize my moves oh wait a
minute um so yeah but i agree bishop takes f6
and 1966. and you know he might just do
as uh you suggested because you both are
like really good in this online blitz and maybe
the thoughts match no but the more i look at it
i i i decided yeah um and i think we b3 is the
is the sort of classroom though maybe there is a
reason that you're 2700 and i'm not you're
being modest since when what happened to you
well maybe one day so he's thinking so he's
definitely you know weighing the options here
a lot of candidate moves he can also oh whoa queen
a4 wow i didn't see that so b5 what exactly is his
idea does he want to take bishop yeah queenifer
might not be the move no knight d6 cd and you
just held black what if we go here and then try to
go after that d6 yeah but like you're suspicious
maybe even knight d5 and you might
be out of the trouble i don't know
yeah ugly queen not to mention that bishop d7
is also possible did you even consider it queen
check no i didn't see it at all honestly very
interesting this junior players they surprised
me with their moves many times uh they play
some moves which i don't ever consider yeah
yeah it's you know you it doesn't even
enter your field of canada moves i agree
that always it unsettles me because i
think wow were our thinking patterns
really that different but apparently
so with with young players as you say
huh and bhutish taking his time here definitely
deciding between b5 and bishop d7 what to do
he'll play queen b3 bishop b5 what do you think
it's fun to predict moose should be five i agree
because bishop takes b7 rook ba white runs into
some trouble although you're not really not sure
yeah just just with that bishop back much like
the first game just recovering the pawn saying
i'm better and that's what he does yeah what about
okay b5 may be too crazy or maybe just castle yeah
just castle yeah i agree i think that's the
most practical and then maybe white goes rook
d1 and keeps the tension queen doesn't cash in
quite yet yeah ah and you have to be a little
bit careful of queen trap ideas yeah yeah
but i think maybe if you take and then take
white has multiple ways of definitely getting an
advantage a minute and a half on the clock almost
like you know i really like to see
matches which are like extremely close
so i'm hoping like you know at least it gets a bit
more uh closer and you know down to the last last
section you know that would be much more
fun than it being one-sided nothing any
of the players though no you're absolutely
right and i think we yeah i mentioned this
yesterday it's not like we're rooting
against the player who has the lead but
as with everybody we want excitement
and action and actually it does play v5
i thought it was over the top but i suppose now
the idea is of course to get this bishop i would
take it i would take it yeah i have a reputation
of being called greedy vd so i would definitely
take it like any i agree completely no because i
just don't see the play in return for that also
that pawn on d6 is very weak you could follow
up with queen before and if okay rook the one
kind of same concept if black goes d5 then you
could put the queen on your board and stop like
queen v4 looks nasty yeah queen before and it's
a dream dream position maybe a5 like black can
do just enough to dislodge maybe queen
a3 with that in mind is a little bit
more i wanted to play queen before and
b3 bishop a3 but maybe it's too much yeah
yeah sizzling down that diagonal now between
a3 it stops black from chasing the queen away
i think he's deciding between those two moves
watch him play something completely different like
f4 i think this is going to be one zero i can yeah
we can easily count it like very hard for white to
go wrong i think after queen a3 there's black is
no moves and then you just sort of develop bishop
before c1 and then you could put the bishop on d6
yeah should extra reinforcement be necessary yeah
i think in blitz do you
think like uh the defensive
um what to say uh the skills of defense are really
important like what are the most important skills
for blitz play according to you're one of
the experts here well i appreciate it i mean
i think this sort of tenacity in defending
that's got to be the single most important um
just given my entire experience at
least in my sort of view this ability to
not only create just cheap traps but actually
defend objectively which is underestimated i
think people think when you're defending in blitz
it's all about dirty traps it really isn't i think
a lot of it is actually about finding objectively
good defensive uh options with it um and trying
to defend objectively find the best chance but i
also think you know things like improvising and
unfamiliar openings and posing practical problems
forcing your opponent to make a lot of decisions
is another underestimated skill because that
sucks at a lot of time who would you consider
like the world's best players in blitz maybe
online we don't even consider over the board
right now right online in three plus zero with
no increment i would say it's very close between
carlson and nakamura i would i would if
it's increment i would side with carlson
and within bullet like one minute test
i would go again i would go ali reza
hicaro and magnus as sort of top three very
very close even ali yeah you would put him
in one oh absolutely if he's on his game and
he is a little bit more prone to tilt i think
than the others in that category but he can i mean
his 30-second chest is is the stuff of lesbian
or you folks can trust me it's like he literally
has the power of telepathy he's like i mean it's
crazy the way that he predicts moves the
way that he can convert a position with one
second left a slightly better end game it's it's
unbelievable honestly it's just the sight to me
i should check that out someday because i think
nowadays most of the chess is going to be online
and i think this online skills are going to
matter a lot in my opinion well you ain't too
shabby yourself with it i'm there but like i'm
like 3 000 30 50 like you know that's my peak uh
but not not more than that i want to you
know uh it would be nice to reach like 3100
yeah i mean a lot of it really is sort of having a
good mouse and and mastering the mechanics of time
scrambles which a lot of to a lot of players is of
course very distasteful and they think that's not
real chess but you know the question is do you
want to i felt that in our match yeah it's but
at the end of the day i mean you just need that
kind of stuff if you want to achieve the specific
rating gains so you never feel guilty about
flagging anyone oh i think that you're past that
stage yeah i actually do because i used to not
feel guilty i used to also do it more obnoxiously
i've introduced a couple of rules for myself when
i would say okay you know these types of positions
i'm i'm not going to go after my opponent i don't
feel great about it but at the end of the day you
know you it's online chess you have to do what
what you have to do you got to do yeah yeah
and stay i think fighting back castle oh yeah yeah
i mean like i didn't think he would ever castle i
didn't think white needed to allow that um i know
i think white is still winning for sure whoa whoa
this does no rook f7 what what was rook
f7 so close you know my instinct here is to just
exchange queens yeah that does not seem like a bad
idea and pinned along black is completely lost
he's gone from the frying pan into the fire now
yeah big difference in strength um we have to
be objective and say what it is so far the story
arjun playing much much better gokesh giving it
too easy at some point like this b5 move it's like
after that you can't really fight back you know
that was a big big mistake do you think he has
to modify radically his opening with black maybe
go for a king's indian or something to that effect
um he can but i feel like there's a big difference
in strength right there i don't think opening is
the biggest issue it's just pure practical
strength and arjun is much more conscious i
haven't seen like a big mistake from arjun
so far i can't recall one where he has like
uh you know played a move which is like
not even like top five or something
and we have a rouser uh here so and uh yeah
i love this opening by the way i used to i've
played like 300 uh games in this line it's
my one of my favorite openings from black
yeah and it's it's become more and more
popular it's so rich um incredibly rich with
so many different uh options yeah now we have
a couple of treats uh for the viewers as we uh
as we observe this opening go into the uh middle
game we have first and foremost live odds and
vidit it was very overwhelming the prediction it's
gotten even more lopsided 93 to 7 the current live
odds uh according to the statistical prediction
for uh what's the best of this odds is if you
can prove it wrong that satisfaction would
be amazing but i don't see it happening today
well if it does he's gonna have to start winning
very quickly but definitely very lopsided and uh
this is going to be interesting but the second
thing that we have uh for you are actually a
couple of photographs and they're not just any
photographs they are photographs of the players
as their younger selves now they're not old but
even younger selves and we want you ladies and
gentlemen to guess the age of arjun and bhukesh in
these photos that you see before you i'm curious
whether anyone could predict the neighborhood
i mean i would get this
wrong what do you guys think
you have seven oh someone wrote six and
three i mean definitely not three yeah
okay we have some close let's see eight and
six eight and six tenants ten and eights
then i actually don't see anyone getting both
exactly right but you guys are very close wait do
you know do you know the answers i think i've well
i've i have the uh cheat sheet so to speak but i i
can i guess as well or yeah please do i actually
want to hear you guys um okay so gucci is i think
six or seven i think i would call six or seven
one of these and arjun is uh nine or ten i think
ten yeah i would go with ten you got one of
them right and i think arjun is indeed ten
uh and drum roll please and i don't know if
i'm supposed to reveal this yet uh but yeah uh
uh is actually believe it or not nine in that
photo nine he's under nine tournaments was uh
but okay it might be an under nine tournament
but he could just be like seven as well
right under nine doesn't mean nine but
apparently he was in fact nine years old
i can't believe that i can't
either so you're saying in these
in this photo there's only a difference of one
year or less yeah crazy anyways ten and nine
is the word that we perceived as we transition
back to the game and here i actually think uh
has a pretty promising opening now you're sort
of the rouser expert i i find it very difficult
to evaluate these positions i wouldn't let you
approach this i would never ever put my king on b7
never ever always on dark square i never
put it on light square interesting um now
g3 i suppose will be played uh i think one of
the ideas is like to play knight e2 knight f4
and uh maybe some queen h3 if you can
get it usually the bishop goes to h3
but even queen might work or there is an idea
of knight to knight f4 knight h5 i don't know
whereas black actually puts the king
on b c7 or something and plays b4 a5 e4
so he's attacks on that flank so i love this
opening for black i have a preacher dice
towards it so maybe you can take white and
pose me problems yeah i definitely if you
like an opening for black i'm definitely taking i
would never even think of it now one thing that i
i've i've sort of seen is the idea of going b4
and then e5 is there anything to be said but
now we have bishop c4 because the knight can't
really get to d5 this looks nasty e5 was ugly
oh wait it happened or not oh 95 happened yeah i
was supposed to game but what i'm really worried
about is an e5 breakthrough for white even
sacrificing stuff oh nice yeah ready has to
be considered in some positions don't want to
calculate anything specific what is knight f5
what is knight a5 bit weird i love this e5 idea of
yours though pretty cool yeah i mean even here it
should be considered although d65 was thinking
of like a check but who knows oh rook d7 here
oh let's see very cool very good we have 92
he's taking sort of the more measured approach
actually and i have uh news for you is actually
six so i was right six or seven i was right
we were misled uh slightly but you were absolutely
right yeah there was just no way i mean there's a
limit to what's possible how can you deny that i
mean he looks so tiny yeah exactly in any case now
you're right he moves the king away to a7 uh he
says let's get it out of the danger zone in the
window of opportunity but for playing e5 and
following up with the check has passed i'm not
sure about 92 well he follows up with knight f4 as
you mentioned knight comes around to see five nice
queen at six yeah yeah i was wondering knight
h5 is it an option that's actually one queen
d that forces me yeah and then the other
knight can come to d4 if required oh queen
e3 by the queen e3 also interesting yeah not
sure what to make of well then queen be said
get on the screen yeah exactly just get
on the board yeah but i'm sure he i mean
this game i i think you can send it i think
he should play for it like play for them
maybe go to catch e1 just and go bishop f1
bishop h3 i mean you have complete control
even if you play like something solid it
shouldn't be that bad because black is stuck
how do you even play with black now yeah no no
attacking chances going nothing going really so
virtually anything is good in blitz do you
think it's sometimes uh better to play like
fast and like uh what to say swapping no fast
and like uh the normal moves whereas not trying
to find the best moves but just play a decent
move i would say 100 better than you know trying
to find the best moves absolutely and i also
think that that there's like a middle ground
where i sometimes tell myself okay i'm going
to give myself until two minutes and then i'm
gonna make a move regardless of whether i i'm
satisfied with my search um and that way you can
compromise a little bit you know you can search
uh but you you know you don't just whoa who what
i would never ever that is crazy now he's
limiting the night uh but what cost what what cost
i mean it's i can't refute it immediately but
i don't like it e5 now yeah it just seems so
drastic now maybe no i think he'll play c3 with
the idea bishop c2 but c3 d5 maybe and give
that pawn put knight and the knight on d6 this
starts to unwind a little bit yeah i think yeah
it's such a high maintenance move yep
yep yep you know it's like before you
it's one of those things you just intuitively
don't don't yeah it doesn't look good
yeah yeah and i think if you even put engine
i think it must say that b4 is not the move
definitely e2 okay so now bishop c6 i guess
does not threaten bishop b4 because there's
queen e3 with the four he does it anyway you
see such tactics so quickly one more tactic
that's that's basically all i see that's what i
have to make a living off but i don't think that
helps white because it's not like why you can use
this tempo to do anything what does white even do
um yeah good question maybe it'll
catch you one and play bishop
back to d back to d3 and this is a huge sign
that things are going very very wrong this is
the game would you play a5 yeah i would i would
introduce this tension but on the other hand
white goes a3 now i would try to get d5 in at
some point the problem is this bishop on c6 is
counterproductive he goes i like this new king b8
yeah he's drawing the king out of the danger zone
rookie one may be white white should be considered
oh look at you one idea d5 95 maybe you know
oh the bishop is undefended i'm learning from
you man learning from here no that was that was
nice now it's not easy for black either h3 now
by location sort of preparing expansion with g4
knight f6 queen f6 or knight f6 yeah queen
f16 is more proactive he does go knight f6
without a doubt and then
take queen e6 also he does
what to do for black now yeah queen a5 takes
yeah he just says i'm not taking any chances but
wait what happened so he gave an intermediate
check okay and this is i love what he's doing
though knight f cities now ruki's g3 yeah queen
c7 oh 997 nice just goes out between d4 forces
the creature and wins the bishop and now you
won or you take the bishop he's making sure
the straight queens look at that he's saying i'm
not going to take that i'm training questions yeah
and trap the rook actually yeah he'll resign good
good game for kukesh finally makes a comeback
b4 for the win wow so it it paid off i suppose
although man man did he go through a lot there
oh charlotte chess center in the chat shout
out that's my good friend videomaster peter
gionatus is welcome welcome um got the whole
contingent here um yeah so another catalan and
the fact that that bouquet is thinking tells me
he is probably rambling to find a different line
maybe we should be seven i don't know yeah
just do something peaceful you know at least
get out of the opening be careful
here good that it's at least 3-1
indeed indeed it goes for dc okay oh it's
persistent now before this gets interesting
uh the producers are telling me we do
have a photo of lucas when he was nine
um which we are just going to show because
we have to save face and there we go that
is the photo of vacation now everybody needs
to be impressed and look at this photo for
a couple of minutes here yeah and gurkish
is clearly visible there yeah very amazing
i think this was like ansel adams actually
took this photo or some famous photographer
it's so much fun to troll though but we're i'm
being asked a question by um the production team
about how you sit at the chessboard i mean is you
know everybody has their posts right some people
grab their their head with their hands some people
cross-legged some one thing i myself do sometimes
is sort of i don't know how to describe it but you
like bob your leg up and down and then you make
the table shake a little bit yeah wait a minute
now breaking news alert what if c3 c3 knight b1
that's the three and b4 yeah this is completely
out of my aha wow that's really cool but he's
not taking time he doesn't know about it the
point just to show the the people the audience
is just after 86 before this rook hangs so you
cannot retain that wedge that you've built in
now is there a particular seating position that
you usually take or do you kind of change multiple
times for the game i i think i've i think
b4 a3 rook b8 like to remove the from the
bin is the theory aha so and and try to retain
this one and there's a very nice move like
a b now you have to take it bishop b4 queen d3
at trying to take the pawn on c3 you can go e5
and stuff you know e4 is an important move though
and what's the nfd trade queensland yeah yeah wow
but the fact that he's got less than three
minutes tells me that he's out of theory
definitely yeah yeah without a doubt yeah that's
that's problematic i think a b there's like an
option of going c2 queen c2 knight d4 knight
d4 bishop g2 and then knight d6 in terms of
intermezzo and then take bishop okay so we'll
see he's got knight e5 now what about c2 here
oh and the queen takes into that mighty force
significantly no longer did this happen probably
let's see it did that might have been an
oversight by origin with no bishop c6 okay
and then i got my c6 but what
if this should be oh bishop e7
and 25 yeah without this bishop the catalan is
just not the same animal okay nice nice stuff okay
so fun game decision game this is big for goquest
but if you want this one i mean it's a one-point
game so yeah no big damage has been done and this
is a big moment when this match happened do you
feel any pressure when you play them uh what do
you mean you mean when i what do you mean by that
let's say if you are in that position would
you feel any pressure of playing or you take on
lunches like little bit more casual definitely and
it's really it's about the people it's not really
about the prize one for me it's about the number
of people watching they know that a lot of people
are watching sort of it's an official event um and
i personally know when i played the sort of katara
uh tournaments i i just my
hands were literally shaking
whereas i can play a match against you know i
don't know some carlson or something casually
and i won't be nervous at all so it really is
it isn't about who i'm playing against for me
personally it's about the sort of the stakes
of the event but that's just my own experience
i'm sure they have their own things that make
them nervous or less nervous interesting so
you're not worried about karl schulzen if you're
listening uh this was an open challenge by danya
i'm always honored and it's you heard it oh
it doesn't matter it's a good move by the way
i like it yeah exchange of the bishop so we do
have a situation where white has given up that
light square bishop out of necessity but queen
d5 can be met with f3 it's not like this is mate
yeah yeah i like what white did now good stuff
maybe you should not have allowed this bishop a3
um right now what if we well a5 isn't
impressive really i mean maybe you
should play it just to try to limit the
knight on b1 but again i mean little k8
yeah yeah bishop a8 and yeah pretend that you're
better yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but if it's a good
move though good movie a5 maybe knight is like
the best way after that and here we go if i play
would you play knight c3 i would i probably would
nice just get it out while you can so so far like
in these games what have you noticed about gokesh
and arjun if you had to like draw some conclusions
from their games i just think the word that
comes to mind to describe arjun is extremely
practical i mean i'm not getting the sense that
he's necessarily better at calculation per se
but he's putting himself in positions and he's
putting vocation positions where it's difficult
to make the right decision and as you pointed
out uh lucas just doesn't seem to be making good
decisions in critical moments i think it's all
about the critical moments there's two or three
points in the game that just seemed to go arjun's
way now some connection problems it seems here
for vacation but he's back online really quindy6 i
think maybe should be considered queen d6 because
there's ideas of of forking the knight on deep
line which of course is going to happen because
yeah it's not but yeah i like white's position i
would pick white what about you i actually kind
of like windy sex i don't know yeah queen d6
takes takes through kate rogan 94 and you know
yeah i don't know yeah so 95 i'm actually
not sure who i would choose i suppose the
time situation is also a big factor here two
minutes extra for um yeah for argentina yeah yeah
goku is a bit slow i would say comparatively and
it's one of those positions like in all you can
have there's so many options here like when
do you play queen d5 do you play f6 yeah like
i said before it's like gucci has to make all the
decisions and arjun is kind of simply reacting and
that actually can be a very good thing blitz but
i agree white's now better the knight comes to c5
okay now knight c4 yeah right i don't want to
play e4 no definitely that seems too committal
yeah yeah queen d8 and some f5 stuff oh he
just done it definitely queen e8 only seems
to be playing into black sands five queen
b5 he played okay knight queen six queen c4
he does he played he played queen eight
winning five seconds g4 seconds only
that was a big mistake oh wow queen c7 now no no
or queen c3 we should be queen c3 queen c7 would
have been but he's got to become three seconds
here but he's got a good position he's played
what is his idea you want no no no he's losing
control he's completely losing
control here he's giving white
cannot leave yourself with two seconds
in such a middle game quite simply
yeah it was like golden chance like you got this
queen eight you had to go f5 it was a big chance
i mean one to four back to a three-point game and
we have another rouser and we have 34 minutes left
in the five-minute portion and it seems to me
um well first of all it seems to me that lucas
is having some connection problems because we see
a red bar i don't see red bar where is the red on
his oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah i was
just looking at black yeah yeah internet issues
i can write a thesis on it they are the worst
there that is one of the most tilting things
just possible so yeah e6 yeah yeah i mean it
seemed that white had a fantastic position um and
there's just so many options in the rouser
uh for black i mean so many setups it's hard
to keep track of with white yeah the only
line i praised and their arjun lost right
yeah commentators first oh i think has some
big internet issues he wouldn't think for
so long yeah he's taking a minute already and
we can see that he's not in a position where
he he wants to do that yeah i this is bad news
bad news because they are like arjun is a good
player you have to have time and yeah that's not
looking good at all so if you were sort of his
like boxing coach after the five minute portion
is that what you kind of tell him um try to
play pastor follow your intuition yeah but
you know um i i'm like objectively i feel that
there's a clear uh difference in strengths arjun
is playing much better than kokesh without a doubt
um that's the so that's an issue so for me as a
coach if i was a coach i would be very hard to
lie to him and say like okay you can do it and you
know this or i would just like tell him um play
a bit faster um trust your instincts like don't
hesitate i see many times he's hesitating um keep
in like a buffer of 30 seconds and just go for it
like you know results don't matter you're like uh
he's just like what 13 14 whatever like very young
and just take it as an experiment and just play
freely because i feel he's a bit like constricted
he's not playing freely he's like little bit
tensed i don't know that's the feeling i get i'm
gonna make a bit of a controversial statement and
i and i don't know if there's any sense in this it
seems to me that there has been this shift among
young players where earlier when i was growing
up it was all about being impulsive the players
everybody was all into blitz and really fast and
now it seems that actually young players have
gotten so deep in their positional understanding
at least some of them that some of them
blitz is just not a natural thing for for
quite a few young talents nowadays is that the
styles have diversified from what they used
to be among young players i don't know i just
got distracted because even though arjuna was
thinking so i got a bit distracted there when
you're asking that question maybe you wanted to
make it fair uh i know i know what you're saying
do you think it could be the reason because he
just thought for a minute to make the times level
some fair play thing going on there nice
maybe that would be very gracious indeed and
yeah well i was just saying that you know it seems
to me that when i was growing up the young players
were all very tactical very impulsive everybody
was into blitz and now we've gotten to a point
where some young players are so deep and actually
so positional that blitz is not natural to a lot
of them which i think didn't used to be the case
but i don't know if there's any sense in that no i
don't think you don't think so like nihal he just
like lives on chess.com but not not all i'm saying
some are as they used to be but i feel like
at least they play even more now because due
to online it's much easier to play blitz
so i feel they play even more uh of blitz
but just the thing is like the strength in overall
has increased because many people are doing it
so that bridge is not there like you cannot stand
out just by uh playing couple of hours of blitz
you have to really invest time now because there's
a difference between like an expert and just being
good at blitz because i think is good at blitz
but he's not three thousand right yeah you just
sense the strength of the experience in every
single game every decisions that he's making
exactly yeah so and yeah so they're both
taking their time we have another sort of
maybe they're talking to each other
right yeah just discussing the position
nikom's step for pressuring e6 but
yeah is there any pressure here um
knight c5 he seems to be a fan of yeah he does
love this maneuver now the knight on c5 lens
support of course to the e61 how exactly does
white continue the pressure does he go knight
h5 and queen h6 c3 i was thinking about
this i didn't ship c2 and put knight on d4
although right yeah i mean that's just like
two moves i see i don't see the rest of it
one thing to point out just uh is that this does
not succumb to a flop because knight t5 comes
with tempo exactly you can't you can't resist when
this when there is a tactic right oh no i have to
show it yeah i just have to i have to show how
proud i am of myself finding a one move tactic
bishop c2 played and for margin there was a
chat which said can we have a match between
vidiq and daniel i can tell they want to play
i do want to play whenever i commentate i feel
like oh man i also want to play oh when i play i
feel like sometimes i want to comment it as well
100 um you just get into the sort of zone
um and you feel the juices the competitive
juices fly how about before again oh my
god i can't believe it i was joking but
no but there's some sense to it because
the bishop comes to b3 and you pressure e6
how about fe first and then bishop b3 because
bishop b3 immediately maybe there's although
even but still yeah yeah yeah yeah but knight
c7 oh he loves these knight maneuvers bishop b3
uh knight c7 i would even play ba maybe ba
queen a5 fe fe and i got excited for no reason
yeah i wanted some knight c6
ideas but they don't really work
pretty so he's got a3 and now bishop
d3 and it seems still knight c7
how about def d is a classy move classy
movie a3 nice right i like that you can
go bishop a2 sometimes queen a2 if required
nice stuff he's he's playing these positions
very well sort of making a measured move when
he needs to and then acting when he needs to
he's at a great position here when he gets
before he feels he feels the position well
yeah it's like it's his move now what
to do now for arjun is there even a
does he kind of sit and wait maybe lend some
support to the e6 pawn with the rookie eight
um not an easy position to play for sure white's
portion is like you can even play king of one
and just like wait and you're still doing good
um yeah this seems like a very important game
uh h5 so he but that settles him with another
weakness you know why did he even consider oh it
takes knight g6 maybe oh nice and then taking this
take 56. you're so good at this quick quick well
i sort of asked myself what the drawback is right
when you move upon like this it sounds primitive
but you have to check the squares i appreciate
it i didn't see 926 at all i was only thinking
yeah i mean once you take the pawn right it's
pretty bad for black yeah yeah it's a very good
tactic i think i don't think he has seen it he
can do it still here even maybe even stronger
yeah but it's a very good tactic thanks i mean
what a bishop b6 though and then you're like no
you can actually take twice
oh no but then some queen six queen c3 i would
just play like knight d4 yeah definitely enjoyed
that he's done it but he's he hasn't got
like g6 oh he lovely knight d5 no knight f5
but it's still okay but yeah this is this gets
a little bit messy but the point is now after ef
the bishop is hanging so you
cannot well you can take the knight
but that's the idea look at the light
square control now instituted by cache
what is going on here now white is
definitely dominating beta i think
yeah yeah yeah for sure without a doubt but
still like you give a lifeline oh seriously
i would never see because now it gives black
this pawn majority even though you have light
square control if you ever lose it black will
have d5 yeah oh it's strange maybe rook c1 now
i don't love what he's done though yeah rook c1
i really like he's done it and then maybe knight
d5 and take queen d5 and penetrate with the queen
oh yeah so somewhere like there if you trade the
knight he's gone d5 there we go very practical
decision again we see the practicality by arjun
and i'm sure i think uh lucas is regretting
you know in retrospect finding that blow
now knight 65 his idea is what just to take
and go king a75 yeah and then rook c8 rook
c8 and okay black is worse but okay it's not
like lost or something yeah white's king is is
of course very weak as well and that's
where the time right was up on time now now
does it look right to you
does it now bishop d5 though
but king a7 rook c6 rook c6 comes in rooks is
definitely gonna play gotta go quickly here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i just
gotta follow his intuition bishop e6 instead
crazy complications here definitely looks to
be in white's favor 96 what about just rook g8
or something okay bishop c7 no queen he's going
after the pawn he can go queen eight or maybe
we need to queen into queen e2 maybe queen it
too but then i'll take on e6 and i'll go bishop
b6 and i'll claim that i have some chances look
at the clock again this is very concerning for a
bouquet she's below 20 seconds he's got a2 rook
to you know seven e7 e7 he said yeah swing the
knight around he's got activated works he fights
okay bishop g6 play quick good movie
seven forcing the rook to tie it up
yeah 95 yeah oh or even queen
c6 just yeah and resignation
much needed win oh he has one only
in the classical sicilian so fun
now this is a huge win and this game i think
fitted he showed this improved followed his
intuition for the most part although he did you
know there were some chances here and therefore
for arjun as well and they're off for i guess
this should be the last match or no there's still
still 23 minutes left i think maybe they're
resolving some issues and we have a karo khan
so arjun's switching it up in a very fashionable
line it's been played in blitz against me so many
times i've seen it everywhere these days this
line with knight f3 and d3 would you change
from a winning line like i don't think
goku had found a solution for this no
i was about to to say he definitely did not
so there's some deep psychology involved here
knight f6 is a bit weird now
you've got d4 now this looks
very good is this a very bad french or am
i missing something i mean he's considering
e6 i'm sure but is there a need to do that
no no no no no yeah just reasonable just d4
knight f6 is definitely not not the way maybe you
go g6 you try to make a gurganidzi out of this
h4 g6 is the move which robert
has would play right exactly i
would defeat him there with h485 and then
designation would ensue shortly thereafter
yep and he's thinking maybe like also knight v6 is
trying to get the bishop out i think that actually
might do but then even like a4 you can meet that
with a5 so something like this try to get the
bishop out not great but at least something he's
done he played c5 c3 yeah normal i mean again i
can see the temptation of going but there is just
no need to engage in this stuff when you're much
better yep or c4 um this is one of the dc i mean
a lot of good moves for white but c3 is simple and
proven yeah but they're thinking so much for like
the initial moves which is a bit surprising for
me i always thought that you have to play a bit
faster um earlier on right but they're taking time
i think the most fun part is when they get down to
seconds that's the c4 wow so he's yeah i thought
about but i thought maybe e6 and no e6 then cd and
then you have this like weak or the structure yeah
with knight c3 so this you're saying knight c3
and you start pressuring the pawn yeah maybe dc
and knight b6 so d5 is the idea oh d5 is the idea
i thought it was well i guess we'll cd on queen a5
wow nice nice now getting back heading back they
did i think here if i go knight d2 and bishop c4
there this black is not out of the woods yeah
i missed this 92 move maybe that's what he's
thinking about no but i think he still has to do
it i don't see an alternative maybe knight b6 here
also is to be considered but but then even e6 i
don't know it's easy to sacrifice other people's
pieces as they say i see a comment which
says be careful hess is a legend on twitch
i think not just on twitch hess is a legend in
general but that doesn't mean that we can't rule
him that's exactly it's why we have to troll him
and robert is a good sport he'll he'll understand
he always does yeah he always does this um so
big time decision here again as you said move
seven and he's gone for a queen a5 track yeah
92 good move yeah maybe 96 then but then e6
e6 i know this looks terrible but can you play f6
and try to just take both of these pawns yeah i
was thinking about it but i would just like play
bishop d3 and give the pawns oh and just there
as well also there was knight d4 in show of
bishop d3 oh just here yeah yeah definitely
stuff yeah yeah so he's got an ipd2 i guess
you have an ip6 it's happening very interesting
uh starting position yeah some sort of
advanced fischer random here not that
there's anything going on in that realm
um so e6 and knight takes d4 are possible
but yeah e6 teams fun game very yeah i mean eight
moves in we've got a very unorthodox position
so e6 f6 knight d4 so queen takes
d5 you could throw in a check on b5
knight c6 yeah and i thought maybe something
to the effect of wow sorry knight f3 maybe
uh push up e6 and maybe knight c6
oh what no castle bishop d7 i mean
right no exactly exactly you just
gift me the pawn and he's got a four
that did it he's got an e4 and he's
preparing to should be five and queen
well the thing is right black can potentially
establish this knight on d5 with e6 and then
he'll begin the process toward development i
think he can even play castle now we should
be fine i'd be three maybe or something i
don't know wow that's really cool idea two
different should pay four though queen d4 i
pretend that i'll have seen it from knights
oh my goodness what madness oh but now
you can you can even move the queen away
yeah but then queen b5 and it's the thing yeah um
okay so knight takes d4 is also a move a lot of
fans of your impression in the chat
by the way i appreciate it yeah i see
what's your favorite i think your grisha
was the best grishok impression i've seen
i mean i i have a lot that i you know i sort of
do on my own stream that i'm not sure i'll do
during the commentary um but i i
do you know i've been working on
i've been working on youtube no i can't
really do an issue i mean i can try to
do a yander pony show which sounds a little bit
like a niche but it's okay but i tried to join
but it sounds a little bit like an issue anything
maybe with a little bit more accents yeah
it does sound like nepo though when you'll speak
uh uh yeah but i i've you know i can try vichy
i've tried um i'll get modera kasparov kasparov
is the one i've practiced the most of course
okay can you do it or it's uh yeah yeah you
know i mean you know my first game you know
gets plugged here it's um you know it's it's
good to be resuming a new chassis you know even
though it's a line you know i managed you know to
create some changes after that you know you know
in the time period you never it some mistakes
you know but overall you know i think we're quite
happy with with the result of my games and you
know we'll see what what happens in the day too
i'm sending this clip to gary
yeah close by you'll just hop in
a car it's like eight hours away
um but yeah there's a there's a couple that i'll
reserve sort of for my stream but people say your
wesley impression is the best impression that's
what this is yeah but can i do it in a commentary
though i yeah no it's very what i and i think
a lot of most people are understanding that i
love these guys i respect the heck out of
them and wesley is one of my heroes so when i
when i do these impressions it's not out of some
sort of disrespect um or or mockery at all it's
actually the contrary and everybody has been
understanding but i also try to be very careful
about making that very clear yeah i understand
because sometimes when i'm like streaming myself
and i make like a roast of anish or something
there are few people who get hurt and they think
that they take it too seriously right so i
know what you mean like people can take it
uh with the wrong intention an
intention is just to have fun to make it
you know a little bit interesting and
then uh people take it in the wrong way
think that we are cooperating yeah
something no completely same with vishy i i
i'm working on that i mean i've got
moderate to i've been working on
carlson is the one that has eluded me
what was that i said sorry about that
what do you want from me what you want me to do
do you want me to let just straight out the
opening and take it all the way to the end
is that's that's how you win smooth game i mean
i can't really it's it's in pre-production here
so in any case we're entering time scramble phase
it seems like white is actually doing decently i
don't know what's going on here i would take white
though yeah clearly for one time bishop but what
is black coast bishop g7 and castles one thing
is that there is a four gonna be seven yeah yeah
so you have that in your pocket you can go queen
before b3 yeah yeah that may be queen before
oh no where's the queen trade queen
before is so nasty i hate that move
that's my one role in life with
it now bishop d2 very measured
very practical arjun twelve seconds though
by the way only right now he's gotta take
this home this is a big chance for me face
knight queen d7 this has to stabilize again
yeah 27 castle i mean he's got the
central control here yeah why is he
thinking queen f6 doesn't feel like queen b3
right the knight is unprotected attacks b7 oh
yeah but still i would take the pawn queen
and start taking the point two seconds
to stop night of four let's see
six seconds now 96 trading nights
we should ship c3 but he's
training off a lot of pieces
what's going on here day two
quincy three oh no no iron
some work remains to be done
here for boucase rook c2
then you go around through the other side
but b5 is going to draw yeah b5 before
you're never sure but yeah yeah i see you've
got to just run that through and be three
no i was wondering even if you can go king you
want king d1 king c1 but that's a bit too much
whatever the 11 minutes ago very practical player
that's what i noticed how we handled the position
d3 he just went rookie four like exchanged
pieces very practical player one thing which
i've noticed about him i agree completely it's
not that he doesn't take any risks but he does
you know he just takes the air out of it and
he's up two points there's no need to go crazy
now he's gonna place he gonna play this for
another 50 moves now again you can lose this
i think if you if you're not careful this
is losable i've definitely lost you know
these types of engines all of a sudden it's
like you're posed with problems really yeah
i think the rule is like you keep attacking the
f3 pawn and yeah rook k5 is also good you just
like do like a fortress there right but you start
pushing the pawns and you know with two seconds
you can panic h5 yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
telling you i think oops i'm bad thank you yeah
i'm telling you a minute this
is scary oh time diamond f5
oh my goodness oh my lens oh and it's still a
drop probably yeah there's no i have no idea
how to draw an f6 f6 when both the pawns are
there it's just winning yeah oh it means what
but it was already lost i think no but still rook
jiwan king i know yeah yeah is a heartbreaker
oh my goodness i i guess i i relaxed and i thought
it's a draw but you your instincts you know your
blitz instincts knew well yeah i could be one
being these situations and it's amazing how
many chances can be generated if you're just
not very precise uh you know increments and
that is a hard record that that game will be
a critical i feel like yeah five two and now
it's uh probably the deciding game of this um
yeah i think should be possibly i guess this
is the last game i'm not maybe depending
on the length of it but the way that the
games have been going yeah probably so
we haven't went over with queen a5.84
um i think dcbc c4 is one of the moves
here yeah i think negi um analyzed the
heck out of this position in his books um this
is i've tried to play this line with a4 never had
any success with it played it against
fabi and got it handed to me but um
yeah that was fun h5 now i think uh you take on
f1 and play f6 maybe because your knight on c6
is better than knight on a6 yes but you don't want
to allow h6 right so yeah but i thought bishop f1
first yeah rook h4 should be played good move yeah
and there we go f1 now dc is potentially a threat
yeah maybe knight quincy what knight is
seven i don't like this move dc and c4
right dc when you try c4 takes yeah and then
rook be one bishop before something you know
right this can spiral out of control very
very quickly i didn't like this movie that's
actually how fab you beat me i allowed something
to this effect but king juwon is playing it slowly
okay but now g4 like this is not scary that's not
enough kimchi one king jung was a bit weird now
yeah but now dc is a big threat so do
you play c4 but then g c d maybe c d
c d g four you form still yeah knight
takes the knight for queen f3 nice
castle though but g5 i mean again it's
not like this brings black any relief
yeah you know what i was just joined in the score
is like 5 2 in favor of arjun and this might be
the last game of the five minutes section and yeah
things look good for arjuna big favorite right
now what if c4 here c4 here dc d5 and just boom
goes the dynamite dania style it indeed and uh
well excuse me queen c4 takes takes basically
before he did no he took first and then c4
but i still like it right he's ripping open the
position one has the feeling that things have
gone quite a bit wrong here for black what would
you play though like next few moves are important
yeah it's like a critical moment
right if black castles goes knight c6
black might very well be better but yeah
yeah i don't think it's as bad as it looks
no i agree i agree maybe queenie two queen takes
c4 just like practically but it's just like life
you know it's not as bad it's not as bad as it
seems yeah very profound i like it we need to play
now these end games can be very double-edged um
i would prefer black though much easier to play
sometimes um with this knight so what do you
do here do you castle yeah i would just cast
and maybe okay but that pawn on c5 concerns me a
little bit um it doesn't to me like takes a knight
no but yeah i agree rook ca yeah i can see
what you're saying although yeah bishop h69p6
just had to point that out i cannot
resist so knight d7 played okay
daniel is the chit great coach and player to lots
of fun ah well thank you mark i appreciate it
it was a chat by the way which i read so
no i know i i'm saying yeah but you know
so um as we uh have a lawyer as they're pondering
these critical moments we just wanted to very
quickly update you on the odds um as they have
progressed we see the bobble heads moving hither
and better but we see of course still a huge
um advantage in terms of the odds that has
remained uh i think that's like a live graph of
the percentage as the games continue but we see
it basically started around 90 it moved a little
bit up a little bit down but it still remains
there now fancy fancy stuff indeed indeed we have
every kind of measurement and we have 89 percent
in favor of margin i think it's shifted from 87
and then it was at 91 but three point advantage i
mean i can understand still i and again i want to
make this very clear we're not rooting against the
player in the lead but i love seeing close matches
so from that perspective let's see what uh goucase
can bring to the table why do we look at how
arjuna how relaxed he is look at him now he looks
so chill oh right when i said that he leans in
but he looks like almost sleepy and like you know
like it's not even a match he's like just there
right assume casual games but he's yeah like
you said everything about him very practical
but was it practical to give away the c5 pawn
yeah that was not the plan why would you do that
i guess rook c8 is what he wants and goes or
actually it's kind of interesting when i look at
it why though but i mean you can just play rook c8
and go knight b6 now this is a bit fancy too fancy
for my liking i like simple stuff i'm a simple man
right and i agree like bishop takes
b6 even then rook takes you rugby one
i feel like white's out of the woods for sure
but case really has to try to win this game
three minutes 50 seconds left my guess is that
there might be one more game after this one
but we'll see him yeah we have like four minutes
or how much yeah three three three thirty
basically um 3 30 basically guys do you think in
the chat there will be one more game i doubt so
i think it might go down to the y well it depends
on on whether arjun is going to take his time
looking how how relaxed he is i think he'll
take his time he wants to take his time
okay people in the chat say no no
this is the last game perhaps perhaps
i have a feeling there's gonna be
one more game but what i've learned
from my match with you is that five minutes is
this neces not necessarily the defining factor
so the game game still the match can still turn
around oh we can turn around yeah but i mean for
goku i mean adjustments have to be made on his
end uh without a doubt group b5 bit ambitious
um i guess not a bad move though not
a bad move yeah so rook takes c2 he
i guess he wants this right he just wants
to take maybe 95 will be played right now
it is
okay oh wait people in the
chat say he could reach 3400
what is bullet edition so they added 150 points
to everybody's bullet rating just.com did a couple
days ago oh i didn't know about this yep i think
to counteract uh some sort of uh deflation so i
i logged in and i was like wait wait a minute i
don't remember being 3200 yeah so it was crazy
i i didn't know about it until it happened but
icaru was i think 33.80 and then he hit 3 400.
okay nice now i actually what is going on here
who is better because these knights are incredibly
jumpy knight before 23 seconds for goku i am most
worried about the time situation here burgo cash
yep yep he's a bit slow bit slow knight f3 but
he wants to win we can sense that by this movie
movement b5 bishop b4 will be played in my opinion
then a6 and a5 a67 yeah a5 a5 yeah yeah then maybe
rook ace yeah but there might be food yeah yeah
looks like it's potentially fizzling out into a
drop maybe a6 or k5 right away go for it that
was a good move right keeping that extra pawn
yeah noun a5 yes bishop d6 rook c4 you know
he might even lose this because some knight f4
idea is knight h5 i don't know a bit scary bit
scary knight f4 93 knight f4 92 i don't know
a lot of threats with 16 seconds you know
you're absolutely right knight d3 93 though
g3 a good move i in my opinion just stop the
knight from coming back great move i agree now
he's going to take and come back to f4 maybe
yeah all rook c4 first oh no then there is uh
then there's a five yeah yeah yeah so
it looks like this will be the last game
oh my goodness oh rook c4 are very dangerous but i
like this for white this is actually easy to play
for white because you wait for it to take in a go
c4 are you sure is it like it's a extra pawn oh
there is an extra i didn't see i thought it was
ankle material but still i don't think this is
this is wow why did i do that again i'm
pressing something on mouse now let's see no
i think losing this would be terrible for him he
uh i guess i would say five yeah yeah i agree i
agree yeah yeah yeah but four seconds still time
is up so this is officially going to be the last
game shot was correct yeah e5 f6 right allowing
this knight to come to b3 should that be necessary
you know the worst thing for me is when you lose a
winning position i hate that like i can't stand it
because i feel it's unjust it's nothing i
don't think it's unjust but it's just the
worst yeah as you said it's the it's the worst
feeling you just it's the most tilting i agree
i guess from experience whenever there's a
passport in blitz there's always the possibility
of a swindle but again arjuni just doesn't allow
swindles he's so he's so practical he's so careful
king fa very measured this is
a disaster very practical as
that's what i've noticed here when you
see these games live you understand them
players better now mm-hmm no that's they i agree
completely that has been the sort of deciding
factor even perhaps was the practicality and
the strength of course as you pointed out yeah
still not over though let's see how who cage
handles this he's actually doing quite well
his favorite moon i'd be seven yeah now oh my god
d6 does not work rook c3 or maybe rook d5 55
rupees oh rook c3 no and then f6 look at him this
is losing just f6 ties the pawn and yeah it's that
there's going to be five yeah f6 king d3 king b4
is over and that is a blow blow for vocation
what a performance in the five minute portion
four uh the predictions were not so far off
i think it was something like seven two or
something six and a half two and a half and it's
yeah yeah it is 6-2 and that is definitely a
blow forward cage however the silver lining
for him is 60 minutes of 3 plus 1 coming up
and so he's going to have to make a serious
statement here as arjun arigaishi uh coming
out to a four point lead after the conclusion
of the five minute portion well we have to
let the players catch their breasts before the
start of the next portion and we have to catch
our own and i'm sure you do as well when we come
back one hour of three plus one coming right up
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
the junior speed chess championship
brought to you by chess kid we have the
three-minute portion of the match between
two shining stars of indian chess grandmasters
domaraju lucas and arjun igaisi coming right up
first let us update you very quickly on
our smarter chess match prediction which
indeed predicted a lopsided victory for arjun and
well it really hasn't changed it came very close
to the truth um in terms of the five-minute
section i believe it was 6-2 right at the
conclusion of the five-minute portion so basically
it's predicted the lead and in order to beat the
odds lucas is going to have to make a very very
serious comeback he's going to have a have to make
a statement early in this three-minute portion uh
and we will have liftoff any second here what are
your thoughts on on how bk should approach this
uh does he have serious chances of overcoming the
odds and overcoming the leads so i think in our
match uh when we played the score was like five
two or five three something like this and um and
then you uh covered a little bit in three minutes
and then in one minute you just took the lead
right so it's still possible to do that and i
guess in three minutes what he has to do is
like reduce the margin i don't think he can
cover it up but even if he like closes the gap
to two points that would be a great uh victory
for him i would say so absolutely that's what he
should aim for like keep realistic games i don't
think it's possible to like really uh kill it
with like you know cover four point margin he goes
of course i'm very biased but i agree i think
that you should and you shouldn't think of it
as i have to come back to make up every single
point it's one game at a time and uh stay in
the game as they say you know coming back in any
sport basketball you hang around until the fourth
quarter and then about that that run in the last
seconds yeah i like that he has already gone for
kings indian like you know i don't care i'll
play kings and i'm sick of your catalan stuff
already a nice vibe there and he plays this king's
indian positions well i know him he likes this
his coach also plays the king's indian i know
his vishnu he plays king's indian himself so
he enjoys such stuff i don't know about arjun how
will handle this it will be interesting because
it's very practical but in king's indian
it can get out of hands so very clearly
and one thing in the king's indian is you could
be losing and there's always this chance for
counter play no matter how lost you seem to be
so exactly that's one of the practical elements
of why it's appealing not only a classical
chess but especially in blitz do you think
yeah no but i there is this idea of going
like knight f7 bishop hd maybe it's slow
now there's always this question do you take
on prasad i would say maybe you should really
i would actually that's sometimes annoying to me
that and then before actually believe it or not
i think he's seriously considering it but we'll
see i don't like it because the knight c7 96 isn't
it like easier for players now that is true but my
point is if you can maybe attack the spawn quickly
go knight b3 and c5 but i also agree with you it
can get out of hand as we said but yeah i think
he's agonizing over it he's looking at the time
he's spent almost half of his time already this is
okay so he's gone queen c2 now g5 is an idea
and then queen g6 i've seen the sack before g5
takes him queen g6 yeah and h4 knight f7 so
tricky king i don't think he did though but
now this gives him the flexibility of potentially
going bishop h6 activating this bishop would you
play long castle and king b1 okay yeah well i
i actually would i would castle then go for g4
quickly because it's very hard for black to attack
right that's why i would castle first i think
and then g4 e4 still is an idea but yeah he
does i think not bad how we handle it not
bad i like it very pro again very practical now
maybe knight c7 and a quick p5 is that any good
i don't think so i think white comes faster
with g4 yeah yeah ah maybe king a cheat
just remove it like for g4 stuff i don't
know brace for impact would you go g4 i would
but he's gonna access you of course would i
would exactly yeah just go for it but it's hard
for black to to make a move here um because gf is
definitely a threat and it's a positional threat
as well because it gives it gets the
four square knight at six interesting
one yeah keep the tension for sure i would
play rook to one rogue g1x ring the king
while you're at yeah i agree completely i
mean that he's hoping of course for this and
the knight's gonna get access to this very
strong square but okay five very committal
f4 what if ef gets this beautiful i
guess he wants bishop but very concrete
i don't like it something is off about this idea
though if you just move your queen away you know
we need three yeah you know me
like better than i know myself
uh you you see a trick and you go forward knight
knight coming to g6 what do you make of this
that's a classy move but what about fe yeah i
mean it looks good i'm not saying it's necessary
i don't like fv though because that forces black
to introduce structural weaknesses in his position
you would want a knight to land on okay rookie
yeah what i'm not sure about yeah yeah if he
was the way you're right fe was the way i feel
like they're they're playing this cat and mouse
game where they're both afraid to just step on
the gas pedal now e4 should be considered maybe
i don't know should it be considered is that
anti-position oh i love when black plays e4
usually because you get this beautiful
blockade on e3 and then some true yeah
i was thinking of combining it
maybe with a quick bishop d7 and
b5 but i do agree with you even that
is not it's a little bit too vanilla
we need seven
i don't like that move at all yeah yeah
no no no this looks bad now knight f3
queen d7 was i'm pardon my french but that looks
like a really weird decision by bukesh there now
h4 has an idea too and now these pawns start
running queen d7 versus i love white's position
agreed this knight on h8 that's where it will
remain if he's not careful and i like the fact
that it's three minutes so we are already in the
time pressure we are and that's going to be ever
again this is going to be a lot of fun knight
f4 active indians 90 does manage to you know
rush past the gate before it closes h6 bishop
each have to do it here we go g6 has an idea
some point knight to six maybe just put the knight
back right but then we should page five yeah
no really i think bishop f4 and g6
he's playing prophylactically he's six now
i always just go g6 yeah he's like position
slowly but okay he does it anyway but no but now
it's not doesn't work rookie six is a positional
idea as well in the same positions right no
but this has gone completely out of control
f3 yeah trying but it's like
you know the lone ranger
i mean g6 here as well he's setting something
up here look at arjuna it is so positional g7
now bishop e5 bishop f6 has to be played nice g7
and bishop d3 g7 and bishop d3 oh what an idea
he's attacking the pawn how do you defend
it i don't like knight c5 bad move bad moon
now black is id rook e3 no but take it he takes
an seven he's seven he can't take it back and too
soon he sensed the moment but this is going to
be appeared to be too even too i could sense
your frustration you all almost broke your mouse
there yeah i mean it just it's like i could sense
that he was sensing the moment and what to do
now though luke is continuing to find she has
f2 he's seven though seven yeah wow hats off to
arjun i mean he just he kept the schools he kept
his calm and he finds a really good idea it's
a time rusher very nice that's a fun time
pressure uh chaos indeed indeed and now a five
point lead yeah was like the highlight for me
yeah i mean i it seemed like the game might have
been turning around but i think he got too excited
you know knights i like knight c3 in
that position transposing into a jabba
is changing he has to change something
arjun proving like really strong so far
yeah this should be three this line
now it's pretty fashionable line
i first side in the game uh i think
kikarina morgan's got a kamsky
in the us championship and since then
i think it became very fashionable
yeah just like to flex here that i played
it against levon arunian and i won again
just nice just wanted to flex a little bit here
so you played with white yeah i played with white
it wasn't world blitz though still
the flex just lost its meaning but
you've you've beaten your share of super jams
in classical as well more than a fair share the
point is like you want to play f5 f4 but then
there is always knight e5 uh right and then
that exposes this knight exactly and then i like
this this but then you go a knight f3 for example
right positional pressure yeah usually i've seen
people go g6 yeah exactly knight g7 knight to five
i played a game with shimanov uh and he did this
and i was just he wanted a piece later but i was
just much worse i mean i just allowed ever like
i didn't find a way to stop all of this stuff
um and uh but again taking his time at f5 he
does it anyway 95 go for it oh 95 bishop e5 d5 f4
boom boom boom boom queen and if you take on h5
he has rook f5 in the end oh no no but uh there
is bishop c5 as well after f4 ah so maybe direct
f4 is a better uh better move got me all excited
and actually here whoops that more people
watching than hikaru's stream just wanted
to say that which is very rare wow that's
awesome um thank you everyone who have joined
thousands and thousands of you and fans from
all across we know a lot of fans from india
staying up late cheering on these incredibly
talented young players we really appreciate
people's participation and hype uh it makes our
job vetted i think a lot more fun and uh so big
shout out to everybody watching and cheering on
um whoever you're rooting for by the way bishop
g5 very bad move you i don't like it at all it
helps black bokeh bishop g5 was not the way now h6
will trap the bishop and it looks bad i will say
that once the games start i think in seven minutes
we'll see about the viewership but let's keep it
strong how old are the players now is one question
i think it's seventeen and four to fourteen yeah
seventeen to fourteen and gucash was the second
according to my research the second youngest
grandmaster in history he was 12 years old um
and that is just that is mind-boggling to
me still but i don't like white's position
e4 no that was really interesting now gf and e5
yeah well not immediately maybe d5 hangs but yeah
and i just don't like them now do you castle
long here but that could run into like a5 a4 very
quickly even a5 here could be an intimidation
tactic there's one message which says how can
within not know his countrymen wow man i live
in india we have billions we are in millions
right and those kids who are so talented so i
can't know their age bad data profile everything
no i i think that that is just a general
misconception about you know countries with
a lot of talented players it's like you know
everyone personally you've trained with all of
them i mean think about the proportion and in
the us i don't know you know i mean i know of
everybody but i don't know many of them personally
by the way just one question like on your streams
uh have you ever trolled like because i'm sure
we get trolled a lot by the chat sometimes
have you ever told back oh absolutely yeah
i i actually do it relatively often um
when i when i see a particularly good
opportunity yeah i know i do it often
um and i particularly like i like to read
messages that are intended to be trolly messages
yeah a particular kind of voice which i will
not reproduce here but let's just say it's
not a very flattering voice guys chat chat go
for it diana just asked asked you to troll him
you know this is your journey no it is welcome
then actually you know i i do like um sarcasm i
like people getting fired up it you know it's
it it adds some color yeah but there is a lot
of color in this position what is going on
here i am concerned about black center f3
e3 and bishop h e3 e3 whoa yeah that is a
knife black is winning yeah that is a knife
and now arjuna will show his technique you
know take away everything be better you might
try something with bishop h3 bishop we should see
it bishop see it who's going bishop h5 my friend
very positional very positional that's a great
move knight f5 and then just bishop c7 even
like you know you're not getting anything oh
bishop i feel like bishop hd bishop afterwards
ship c5 bishop g6 bishop bishop right gg and if
is queen d5 anything there though oh knight yeah
i got too excited for no reason 96 queen e5
queen d5 i would not take on d5 i would maybe
even take on b7 you get a point oh that's such a
good move oh and that is a good one ninety five
what to do now this is so crazy he's
got some meeting ideas queen e6 baby
queen e4 okay not a bad move but now the queen
queen f4 24 okay and h2 i made a certain quid h6
he's gonna move the rook now knight f3 is a big
threat he's got to move forward two seconds oh
that's a knife king one and that's knight knight
c5 oh man oh my goodness that he's so impressive
he keeps putting all the pressure look at
this this way that way bishop d3 beautiful
my favorite game so far of
the yeah it was incredible
my favorite game that was so damn good like the
accuracy level of arjun in that game was amazing
how fast he put played really really cool wow
i think we should show that seven yeah you show
that again let's see if we can very quickly just
uh show that move as the game continues here
rook t so bishop d3 queen d6 by goku
now if you take the wrong queen fe check
and you lose the queen and arjun in
a second rook d7 in this position
now the queen defends the rook you have to take it
takes and it's a fork and you cannot you're out of
resources and this was just part of it even before
he found a lot of good moves incredible stuff
this is very cool love it look decent and how
he played before that you know to even get there
uh because the position was little bit dicey
threatened some 181 in c2 ideas very nice very
nice respect absolutely and um arjun here with
the white pieces we have a rogozin structure
the speed of rook d7 is still i'm amazed by that
how great we played it because like i could see
panicking you know it's like a fork and you lose
a piece and he just uncorks it all his experience
uh showed up there of this online blitz there
is a time control that i played with them which
is 10 seconds to start the game and you have a one
second increment and he is incredible that's where
he shows his ability to just find one resource
after another by the way yeah i was thinking about
that i mean that seems like a favorable trade
yeah but still i like black's position definitely
by the way i have a tendency to say portion
instead of position do you also notice that i
noticed it just as you said the last time yeah
okay oh g5 nice
nice nice spot there in the chat g5 i did not
bishop g3 the idea is to take and of course
does a counter-attack though
oh indeed the transparent
that's awesome what if g4
do you have to do that g5 g4
you do as no that's completely losing the
point yeah king of one speaking h1n1 yeah
basically every game yeah yeah what to do right
it's almost losing here that is uh you see the
face cam yeah he looks completely chill like he
is so chill right there okay another day at the
office yeah but with such a big lead i mean you're
just not too concerned about you know one loss
and um 41 minutes left now this is not over
you know there's plenty of time here the cage
does mount a couple of wins yeah yeah at least
destroying back one interesting ghoukish is higher
rated in classical chess than arjun and his three
years youngest good that's really interesting
okay so he's gone bishop e5 but
uh the problem is he might not even f3 you're not
even going to take the bishop you're just going to
knight oh but then he'll be four yeah but even
just bishop before yeah he's done i mean he has to
knight d6 e4 knight g3 also e4 knight g34 94 by
the way that's the way just 94 now or here 94.
yeah yeah yeah great catch yeah this is the way
to do it that is a great that's how we wrote it
but it's taken and i think that's also good
right ed oh yeah yeah this is also very good very
practical right high quality chess right there
classy decision right there a sensing that it's
just hopeless right with that pawn on d4 phoenix
is what i learned from today's stream is to castle
and move the pawn in front of the king yeah it's
been ubiquitous in these games queen f6 laying it
on i mean b6 okay i guess also good i just thought
we never should have had were there any draws
between them oh i didn't think about it were there
any drawers not at all no results that is critical
chad very nice very sharp what is
indeed now as you know what i'm thinking
rook f6 and then some c5
with knight g3 6 in the end
c3 i mean here you just got to be practical maybe
just take on d4 is there anything wrong with that
um no i don't see i don't think but yeah it's just
lost when you get g5 or b4 i just forget that i
know kukish is going to win it mm-hmm okay it's
never over with arjun he'll always find the chance
g4 c3 yeah just pushes the pawns i mean no
counter play basically c2 simply drive it in
okay just don't blunder the knight on e3 right
and very important yeah should be three i mean
you know when i get this question i feel like
you should finish them off before they get
a chance like just kill it yeah exactly
i would say knight d1 here just wins on
the spot i think because the back rank is
yeah yeah yeah 91 is a good move knight c4
bishop c4 probably also fine because
rookies we need three no no no no no one
yeah that's over that's nice that's
nice right nice finish takes queen d1
coming back but of course it is still
wow five point lead even after that win
and he goes c4 so changing it up a little
bit let's see what he comes up with here
nice nice come back so this it was six two arjun
has won two games and ghoukish is won his first
game in three minutes section now quincy to
g4 incoming oh no this uh actually uh nihal
played this yesterday quite a few times against
uh andrew and robert and i were a little bit
surprised but i guess it makes sense i mean now
it's transposed into something more conventional
d4 i guess i'm not sure that you usually
play d you don't do ah you go like 92 yeah
yeah play but i don't know these
positions very well very simple
i mean 94 at some point might
be considered as well 92 young
c5 and maybe like you wait until the right moment
to decide whether to play d3 d4 or nothing at all
um sorry yeah oh so is c5 um i always used to love
to play you know 94 and some knight f5 even at
the cost of like some material but just g6 yeah
100 tonight age four you just slam it in there
yeah but it's all good in dreams just like you
know most of our dreams exactly yeah it's funny
how during the game you just come up with these
crazy lines in the queen sack and then you know
like not uh scintilla of it will even happen
but you still keep thinking about it hikaru is
catching up he could have crossed us over all
right we need to step it up folks step it off
knight c5 hype dream that's right d4 so he does
succumb to the d4 temptation 95 c5 you're okay
um 95 i like white how he's playing you
know just keep it casual yeah but c5 i mean
it to the good a5 okay a4 go
a4 don't think what about h4
h4 you know you don't know yet he goes g4 not
h4 right the right flank this is now i think
of it you know he might even go f3 g4 knight g3
who knows yeah no and then knight f5 no actually
he's preparing some knight 65 ideas so
sort of prophylactic prophylaxis but a4
and now he gets the b3 score potentially for
the queen arjun going after the queenside
pawns ba was actually a very committal
decision maybe it's time to consider g4
h4 makes sense now to trap the knight but then you
don't even have f3 because right that's the issue
yeah i mean it's very such a such a super you
know artificial idea rarely works yeah yeah yeah
what if you go h4 and then like king h2 alpha zero
there was one message which said that i say gg
instead of gg what does what is the difference
no i think you say it normally oh it does so i
mean all right next game it's game we go gaga
or last last game channel asking all right so wow
you know queen's gonna just you know just take
the pawn on a4 and well black's gonna get some
pressure pressured on the a file so he does go
f3 uh who's who's impressive is that wow what who
whose do you think that was who does it sound like
a last game shot last game chat oh hikaru yeah
okay i mean that wasn't great but no it's like you
know have you seen anish's impression of hikaru so
it's just like he goes a little bit over the top
and then that's why it's stuck in my head uh like
yeah normally i do as well your bitcoins like you
know restricted on this live commentary all right
right go wild watch cool right all right it's
queen bee three everybody takes a four takes takes
takes takes takes takes takes takes takes logical
all right so in any case but this is heating
up a little bit exactly exactly right right
all right now bishop e6 is is that a threat
b6 was a threat but then there was rook before
that's why so that's why he played a3 now the
rook ship again arjun's so careful he keeps posing
problems with every move even his defensive moves
pose problems now does he take
any oh no no then c7 that's bad
hikaru wants to know your location
what is going on chess banning
that's hilarious take on c4 of course
you would of course you would i don't
yeah eddie jake's in rook c7 he did it he did
it no but white is just winning there i think
no there's a million ideas
at the end look how excited
can just take and play rook at seven now i was
thinking about that but then queen g65 oh even
better oh my goodness wait what is this this is
not so clear what if you give a check bishop g7
check yeah yeah rook takes c5 and then you find
some good russian move like h5 h6 what if you go
this this h5 and then and you can leave the rook
on cc okay that doesn't even do anything there
is a beautiful idea though yeah it's right six i
like i like i don't know about this now it's okay
queen b1 at the very least
yeah but now it's like i feel oh time for
some queen b1 check now you have to be
careful yeah that could be possible b7 rook b7
uh e4 is nice nice but but rugby seven maybe just
right rugby seven is less okay but he had to make
a move oh i don't like this at all queen c2 queen
c2 bishop g2 queen for queen f2 oh yup yup yup
again it's those critical things he's but now
he's yeah he's crumbling under the time pressure
winding his pockets with the pawns queen d3 even
yeah yeah yeah okay no this was bad yeah e5 five
the queen is so powerful in these positions
kings king c8 king c7 f4 for bishop d5
yeah yeah just play bishop d5 he's gotta
try to push his h1 that's the only option
yeah yeah h5 d3 h6 d2 right seven queen h8 h7
d2 h7 oh quidditch one and it takes a quidditch
one back bait quidditch what is it made take
stakes and then queen of three and back to h1
what's a draw it's a drone wait it was a draw
it was transposed to it no it turns out only
one oh my god he could have played queen and
[ __ ] and i was completely witty there was
no need for that at that point right are you
sure of queen f3 queen oh [ __ ] catch queen
before yeah was there actually bishop
f3 was also probably me but then king f4
amazing stuff man i thought it was made i missed
i think he missed the same thing i did yeah which
is definitely that square all good blitz player
missed the same amazing it's nice some pattern
sebastian back to principled staff
rook a4 no rookie for a5 so you go bishop a6
yeah yeah yeah now you play castles or queen e5
yeah queen d6 yeah rook b6 this is the city yeah
bishop b7 is the move here knight d5 rupee two wow
castles and now bishop e6 bishop c6 is the
move i feel the bishop is out of the area first
queen c5 yeah it's good move quincy five as well
bishop g4 man i would be so terrified of
playing this if i didn't know what if this
should be five check there uh i don't worry
know about it like i just take everything
for night season king d1 and yeah a3 indian
okay but still pawn but yeah who knows
bishop g4 though and even after bishop b5 there
is king f8 if required but again arjun's showing
superior superb preparation
in addition to everything else
what to do so bishop g4 well the thread is
obviously knight f6 knight f6 that even though
it might not even be like a whoa whoa ship c6
97 king e7 i think it's all good it's all good
yeah queen g3 and now you have to play accurate
uh words of wisdom there right i don't know how
accurate though but i think rook 8 maybe 27 27
runs into this maybe and if rook v6 like this
yeah that looks like king e7 queen g3 and
then k8 maybe so counter attacking the bishop
maybe give it checking f8 and zero zero zero
it's so quick so sleepy though this is so sleepy
yeah he's just moving around in australia
he just doesn't now is rook v6 bishop e5
actually something yeah it is something it's
winning we need six there maybe he's done it
look be one why not bishop p5 i think this is
it because bishop before i maybe like queen e6
oh something i mean that's got to be oh yeah
oh but then queen takes a four yeah but rugby
okay so he's gone okay this
is like he's so practical
three he's got over three minutes a minute
it's got over three minutes look at this
yeah over three minutes indeed it's
crazy takes okay it takes it would be six
i can't believe it it's a
brilliant idea if the word defended
what's the big problem with
squares defended so what
now you know the pin is eternal you
know like queen c5 just queen c5
yeah i love the queen's 5's a great move i was
thinking h3 but there's no need to make luft yet
yeah rook do you want also move i then
this is such an enjoyable position yeah
these positions are so fun rook d1 does
threaten actually bishop c6 and queen c6
but then black will go he does go h6 i guess g6 uh
g6 is ugly it does look very weakening queens if
i go for it my friend queen c5 you know quincy
is one of the moves that i want to play it and
if it doesn't happen it pisses me off it's like
that no i get it it's just such a move you have
to play because whatever you do afterward you
can do after you play queen c5 nice nicely put
you know why put off for tomorrow what can be
done today which i never advice i never follow
g6 he's thinking okay he has three minutes
it's better to think atmos at least some point
about silence well taking
a lot of time here i mean
i don't understand why not queen c5 i'm
like what is the counter argument to this
we need a breather here this is what's going on
chad i'm taking how's it going how is it going
how are you guys doing hope everyone's enjoying
the match we have a lot of people across platforms
we appreciate it um this has been a lot of fun
a lot of great games incredible performance so
far by arjun of course rook d8 and queen c5 is
that possible is it even worth calculating that
so bishop fish queen are
faking f6 queen h8 king e7 yeah
at least you gotta draw so right now you don't
have to it you don't have rookie yet yeah
i missed that well that would be something i would
suggest yeah let's see what happened he has simply
taken again very practical he's not saying no i'm
not calculating anything in particular i'm simply
going to go for queen d5 i think but i didn't
like this h4 move you know queen c5 was much
classier though i agree i agree windy five now
and then queen c7 rook d a first five now rook d7
yeah the match is low i think it's yeah it's
not looking good here yeah and six points
is too much well it's been done before and i
think it's been done once i think the highest
and perhaps we can confirm this but i think the
six point comeback has been achieved before what
is the biggest comeback i think that might be the
biggest one but perhaps some of the historians
speech image pistols in the chat can inform us
um now the thing is in the bullet you can win two
three games in the blink of an eye so 23 minutes
left if he wins two games and he brings it to four
he'll have a fighting chance 23 minutes uh for
the three minute section right correct he can't
let this faster further he's gotta bring it
to four and another one of those b3 g3 lines
okay she takes on d5 wait wasn't arjun the one who
played it the last time or was it in fact yeah it
was arjun who won with black with the crazy no
it was a draw this crazy perpetual in the end
oh yeah yeah so d4 another practical moment i
kind of like it i like arjun style in general
but i don't like the move or d4 which seems a
bit too much it does i agree this is a this is
an extra pawn after all yeah and i'm greedy
so i like pawns extra there's an old russian
joke which is i pointed it's not even a joke
it's just like something russian russians say
or russian coaches say when you sack a pawn
and like your coach thinks it's unsound he says
there used to be a there's a russian
international master his name is
um and he the story goes that when he was
analyzing with people like tall he was
outmatched right he didn't want to suggest any
variations but the only thing he would say is in
my opinion black is up upon and and so my coach
would always say that in uh international master
of natsukanyan's opinion white is up upon he'd
say the one thing he knew nobody could argue with
nice state the facts absolutely but i've
experienced this for sure where i'm and you know
if i'm even near like have like the world team
champion should be bonjour i'm pretty much sitting
silent and i'm just watching i'm i'm so afraid
of suggesting something stupid in during the
analysis i mean i think this portion looks good
for white completely yeah look at this spawn on
d4 is supporting the knight wow square on c6 so
this is gonna be a big game if you can get it
relatively quickly yeah and then that black game
uh that comes up is going to be crucial assuming
he wins this so knight c6 no that's some so what
do we do here queen f3 and cd knight c6 maybe
sorry um what were you saying uh yeah i was
gonna say queen f3 and knight c6 maybe but it
seems like he's executing it mm-hmm like cd nice
spectacle like one c7 yeah what i've learned today
is like be very practical when it comes to blitz
you don't need to find the best moves just play
uh normal like now 97 dc bishop f6 looks good to
me and i would probably go for it right no yeah
exactly like find the top one of the top three
moves yeah those problems consistently and i think
uh is taking a page out of argent's book here as
he does that yeah exactly that type d7 played um
probably just dc i would play right now knight d5
also a good move um also good move 95 but maybe cd
and 95 queen e4 f5 you know yeah yeah and like
if you need to there was a tactic bishop b8 oh
nice rookie now wait a minute
now he's got to be careful and f5
rook takes e5 oh yeah rookie
five you have but okay still
still yeah i mean even in there so
f5 i think has to be played quickly
so f5 what we're saying is of course you cannot
take the pawn because the knight is dislodged
it depends if the knight is dislodged you have to
play queenie for to keep contact with the knight
unless you want to sack the queen which
is kind of out of the question to me
i mean i don't see anything immediately wrong with
queen d4 maybe black can play queen d6 no but yeah
yeah no you have to play queen d4 he does by the
way i see that uh all of my moderators who are on
my youtube channel are in the chat so just wanted
to give a shout out to them thanks for joining in
26 played now rook d8 rook d8 is a threat so maybe
f4 f4 f4 knight d7 97 f4 97 97 ooh exposing yeah
what a tricky little well you
know what what what to do here
yeah yeah it's come back you know such chances is
consistently missed oh wait what oh 97 97 seven
queen queen freaking man seven rookies six
every move is like causes these calculational
difficulties quincy iv though yeah right
king h8 will be played instantly yeah because
otherwise there's discovery of course are you i
say instantly and then he takes 10 minutes knight
takes b6 i mean this has got to be bad now yeah
knight b6 is a good move queen d2 king h3 even
or king f1 both just king f1 white will be fancy
yeah it's okay knight a5 now knight d7 is
possible followed by queen before queen takes a5
95 okay can you also go there's got to be a win
here queen a6 greedy i'm being greedy oh knight
decent and queen before is what you want to do
right yeah yeah just simplifying knight d7 and
recover the knight simply and up two pawns yeah
taking a page out of arjun's book right yeah
just and i've also learned oh wow queens is that
actually good i doubt seven takes c5 takes six
yeah it's still winning it's still winning because
you have two connected passwords h4 h4 h4 i would
have played h4 right the preserve okay rookie
one rookie one go for it rookie one rookie five
why ninety five no where is he going yeah 95 was
no not g5 come on oh my goodness it's main threat
okay yeah oh and nice this is a game he had to win
he's panicking under time but okay six
2k6 he blundered oh no way to save jesus
nothing doing nothing yeah yeah under the rook
here amazing yeah now now he'll win it off
bringing the lead to five now this is the
critical david and i think if he has any
chance of a comeback at all which is slim
admittedly it is here it is in this game
five point lead with 15 what is this
i i think you're uh grishok i
would love to hear your grishok
about the match what do you think about the match
well i i think that okay argent very practical
with mutual time pressure of course he avoided but
no but i think by and large she sort of managed to
get kind of his positions and no i mean i reminded
me of course when i was younger i tried to play
similar style and okay give a couple of years
maybe then good will be a little bit stronger
this is so damn good man i'm fine now i
appreciate it yeah i've gotten a little
bit better at grisha over the over the
months no that wasn't crab necro that
you know that's the worst when you do an
impression in people's lives yeah exactly
exactly that's that's something right exactly
exactly but i think most people are concerned
no this is definitely not great this is definitely
autographic i can't really do a good criminal but
kramnik is like no but i mean okay but here
no here i think white is union okay but i mean
no but somehow i saw take could try
to try to make some progress but
but okay i mean i know but kramnik is more generic
okay i think richard has that particular accent i
can't even really do a good camera no no i think
your grifshook is like the best so far i love it
by the way nice position over the board like
i prefer white very simple to play maybe
he does a better grisham than grisha i think
wesley might be my best one but i'll save it for
for a rainy day no there's too much suspense
come on we can have a wesley but okay i think
people maybe will allow it because they they
know that i'm i really respect these players
and i'd like to thank for the opportunity
that's good
but i'm holding myself back a
little bit yes yes i can see it
especially i can also try but again i don't
want that to be misinterpreted no i don't
think it would be misinterpreted okay it won't
right now yeah uh vichy is a hero of mine again
i want that to be known by everybody we hear
you're not indian so it's fine you can sure okay
oh well i i think that uh well in
the opening i thought a good cache
got a good position but after h4 it was uh
well i thought um it was a little bit unclear
but after uh well after the opening i thought
um well i thought it was quite unbalanced but
uh well after that i managed to create uh some
chances and uh well i took it all the way home
i would say still grisham wesley and
then uh everything else yeah yeah
i think you can sense that it's very far i think
people who are like can't detect the intonations
like you can tell anonymous is very far but i
i have some of it down i think people say that
it's good most of the indians they agreed that
it was there so that's a compliment in itself
yeah no i need to start practicing
others it's getting old you know
camaro and stuff like that oh komarov yeah man
that's his commentary is lit i don't know if
people have seen it but it's the best thing on
youtube it is amazing now the knight comes to c5
and i like get so excited they want lego too oh
i try to do it knight p3 here for uh arjuna and
try to go to c5 and f4 here for white in is his
position i think he's definitely better now for f4
and eight takes b6 for guys in knight p3 knight
c5 with the winning position here for right i
think this is uh this is going to be winning
kill for sure b5 now get the knight to c5
and it's going to be winning this was a lego yeah
yeah yeah it's incredible i was very well prepared
yeah now this is actually total domination for
white by the way this is yeah yeah clearly night
six nights you've got some in you yeah
nightbeat now the only thing you've got
to watch right is the spawn on before which
is actually a little bit difficult to protect
yeah yeah book c1 very methodical look
at this pressure that he's putting on
incredible i don't like ruxin oh knight
b3 queen before was the problem oh
right well that's the thing right
a3 you could have tried yeah yeah
yeah now he has to keep control
but how do you do that queen
now knight b3 becomes a possibility
right queen e7 what if queen g3
oh queen c7 go for it queen c7 gg that
is such a wait but queen takes before
you can't let me have the
movement yeah no did it no
you cannot have the moment i have to take it
before it's so good queen before it's so good
yeah what to do actually because now the
knight comes to g3 yeah this queen before
is a nice trick yeah bishop g4 knight
g3 um not really there maybe queen c5 no
are we sure this is after queen c7
queen before yeah knight g3 go for it
careful now there's a fourth threat
yeah f5 is too much so bishop ca maybe
yeah it's typical dania move bishop yeah
definitely oh bishop f3 rook c8 even ruxin
now f5 magnus carlsen
you have a potential there giving f1 queenie
one by gandhi one he plays the knights the 26th
time pressure now takes 96 check will he leak with
eight no he will not magnum hikaru nakamura knight
before check in okay so anyways that was so good
i think komodo is there like it's one of your top
yeah a little bit more work yeah yeah nobody's
there i could sense that good good stuff the roots
d5 now somehow arjun he he controlled for a couple
moves and then he just right back at it incredible
giving that 45 he will win the game queen is
seven night up for what is sufficient going to
win no it's not sufficient for what am i saying in
different watch rook for who cap seven check the
xd6 nakamura will win the game magnus carlson
queen c6 trade queen and i don't know how he
does it for hours though like i can do
it and i'm out of breath in two seconds
i love it this is stupid man i
appreciate it yeah it's fun it's it's
yeah i've got a lot of work to do and arjun wins
six also has a lot of work to do to come back
you know guys now it's back to a six-point game
now he's got to win this one seven minutes and
change left there's probably going
to be two more games in this segment
yeah seven and a half minutes left right yeah
close to one to c4 we have another one of these um
but there's people like svidler who are almost
impossible to impersonate yeah really i've tried
many times cannot seem to even come close i've
never observed him so closely i think hikaru is
because you see him so often that it's responsible
right right right right exactly right i mean
yeah yes exactly but i think that there are
certain people who have you know well it reminds
me actually of a story from why kansai uh 1974 jen
yes so this is another one of those kind of setups
before there we go again with another g4
yes's voice and that impression i almost
fell asleep that like so soothing oh it is yes
i mean the way that i tell stories is intended
you know to really bring these characters to light
exactly precisely yes and now give me the pawn
give to me the pawn he likes that phrase yeah
the yasser would take one also push him baby
baby no what is that from you have not seen this
push him baby of yasser or on chess bra they had
like a video made about it because whenever he
sees a pawn he's like oh push him baby and then
you know they made like a remix of it i haven't
seen that i need to watch it you should see this
that i definitely will i'll actually write it down
that sounds like something i find entertaining
yeah so what do we have here so he has taken the
pawn in fact and now the g file pressure this is
kind of a typical position that arises right
what do you make of this bishop i think now
96 i would play by the way night before some
annoying move yeah indeed yeah it seems to me
i'm a little bit skeptical of white's player
even though i like the style of playing
yeah you would take white don't know
still i would still yeah definitely
but king i would be grudging anymore you have a
thing for such direct attacks oh i like that yeah
now the issue maybe don't just double rooks
play caveman style he does go king d1 first
people are upset that you don't know push
him baby no i have gaps in my upbringing
i was too busy doing mastering impressions yeah
and getting like 20 30 100 and blitz doing some
irrelevant stuff exactly exactly so 96 now your
move knight comes to b4 very unpleasant idea i
mean you have the open g5 but what do you do about
it right yeah night before tonight night eight
it's like you know it's not it's in
spirit he played g4 and this stuff
but he probably doesn't like it right in my
opinion he's doing it just yeah kind of out
of desperation almost he's got to try to
generate chances quickly yeah i agree yeah
so d3 yeah now arjun's sort of spoiled for choice
he can go knight before but he doesn't a four
knight but what is the idea 984 because
the queen then has the c3 squad also
yeah knight f4 i don't understand
this knight before queen c3 b5 then c5
that's a nice line let me show that
knight people whether it's here
92 and then b5 yeah even after c5 92 oh
so because you can just yeah yeah you
can interchange the move order yeah exactly very
very nice takes doesn't mean it happens let's see
night before queen d2 has been played
he's played b5 knight back to c3
now time for black to okay now if you take
dc okay knight e4 is not a move maybe yeah
yeah is it too risky to go e5 no no no f4
there's bishop f5 a3 e5 f4 and bishop f5
no but a b and bishop b3 then i think you
would do it no i think he is preparing to
sack the knight and simply leave it on b4 a3
now would you think do you think he'll play
i think he has to try a3 but maybe even knight
a6 you know that pawn becomes weak rook g2
seems a bit too small i mean even if you double
there's g6 yeah yeah jesus is exactly what i think
is going to happen yeah yep knight h4 perhaps try
this action you have to know h4 should be eight
we should be eight without a doubt arjun
style i figured out arjuna after today's match
i think i found it we're gonna go and i'm not sure
d4 just provoked e5 you know yeah i was thinking
yeah the knight of f5 becomes
a threat potentially yeah
what to do here is the question 30 seconds for
margin two not easy you know not easy to find
moves right now to find anything really yeah
maybe cd and then like e4 i i was thinking e4
right away and some queen n6 but
it felt wrong f3 preparing e4
yeah f3 if you play f3 i'm just leaving i'm
leaving the commentary right now you're hanging
up there exactly e4 e4 played yeah adapting queen
h6 is an idea then f or d what do you do i think d
these looks more normal yeah yeah somehow yeah
and then maybe c5 knight dude it's heating up
guys 94. look at this i like it i like it i need
four you like h6 rugby three knight g6 i feel like
what there should be enough here but rook v3
first that's very good oh no yeah ninety-five
knights boxing him in winning the queen no i
wouldn't even play rugby two queen h4 and play
this you know just oh yeah this is everything yeah
nice very cool very cool amazing again okay not
over yet though queen f6 queen f6 gg is going to
be a massacre with queen c3 are you sure though
yeah queen c3 look at how practical i mean
he's just safe and now he's gonna go after him
amazing nice rookie two four thousand very
practical very practical queen b3 knight c5
keep soldiering on queen b c3 played although i
don't like d4 yeah i think that was sort of oh
yeah default was a big maybe he might have chance
now maybe right has chance i don't think so though
it's too too much rook b2 coming in bishop h6
they're coming in from all directions yeah zombie
apocalypse king f1 though look at him quickly
he says he's boobs king of eight king of eight
bishop what queen of three oh rookie one
oh it's me wow wow can you believe that
yeah that was very that was great that was
15 seconds left which means one more game
and they aborted no i think they are not going to
start the new game that concludes an incredible
i think three minutes section was my favorite
of like better than five minutes for me
that was scintillating stuff and time and
time again arjun proving himself up to the
task putting on incredible displays in time
pressure outside of time pressure positional
tactical all over the place and off to a seven
point lead coming into 30 minutes of the bullet um
your hot take video on that that was incredible
yeah some nice games you know especially the last
15 seconds when it got down to the wire
arjun really showed his class there
i feel very quickly finding
resources very practical
yeah very high quality stuff absolutely and he's
going to have to carry it home 30 more minutes of
bullets to go kukesh will try his best to mount
a miracle come back don't go anywhere we will
take a short break and when we return the final
portion of this amazing match coming right up
so
welcome back to the junior speed chess
championship brought to you by chess kid
we have concluded two of the sections the
five minute and the three minute section
in this amazing match between indian grand
masters arjun arigaisi and uh bukesh uh it's
been a pleasure commentating and a privilege to
commentate along with grandmaster avidi budrothy
and we have one more section remaining
30 minutes of oneplus one it has been an
overwhelming performance uh by arjun but don't go
anywhere anything can happen now before we jump in
let's walk very quickly once again through
some of the logistical details so we have
30 minutes left of one plus one 16 players
and here you can see some information about
uh the structure of the uh of the tournament
itself uh and now let's quickly walk through
the prizes because these players are putting
their hearts out on the line but they're not just
playing for honor there's very serious prizes on
the line we see the winner receives cool 2 500 and
what may be even more valuable to the players
qualification to the speed chess championship
um which is of course a very very um prestigious
event and a fascinating one in its own right
so a lot of prizes on the line here and uh finally
vidit the match score progression uh which was
always overwhelming for arjun what do you make of
that yeah and first of all i would also say that
it's a pleasure uh to do commentary with you danny
and uh hikaru krishuk nepo all of your avatars
and i'm just curious what is the
prediction and was it like so accurately
this um parameter but okay we have the games
have started we might get there was like it was
essentially you know this is what was predicted
um so was it like the exact same like six enough
to enough and seven three and three plus
one okay i'd be interested if i i think um
i think we'll we'll find out but i i'm
pretty sure it's very very similar but
yeah i'm wondering if it's almost to
the letter but here we have liftoff um
exactly the same moves incredible now he has
played knight c7 before i don't think he'll
go long castle now yeah it would be fun to see
who is good in bullet that would be very nice
i still like g5 in a certain should be five we
should be five go for it yes look at this i love
your g5 idea i love it if you can show it right
g5 takes queen g6 and then you skewer the pawn
on g2 you get this queen out and you pressure a
g2 so you accomplish so many things in one move
um i'm still thinking or no oh bishop f6 played
nice oh my bad yeah so there's couple moves
played now queenie's seven i like black's
position here white if he gives away this
bishop the dark squares around his king become
extremely weak i like uh's position so far yeah
97 a very nice move i think 97. i didn't want
to exchange yeah i didn't i thought maybe ah yes
knight 65 of course i didn't realize that i was
on v3 okay bishop h4 nice provoking g3 good stuff
come back yeah i would like to put my both of
my rooks on f5 but i don't see it happening
right away right why does control now he has
control king g2 and rook a6 to be considered yeah
yeah yeah i think in the last few moves it felt
like white out played black right and look at the
time situation 20 seconds up that is a huge time
advantage in the bullet now doubling on the a file
yup i think he's got to take on g3 but here we
see the consistency of arjun is much much higher
bishop takes bbc yeah queen d8 now this should
be played wait wait wait what he didn't take
on b6 why now now black gets some chances
here wait a minute look at white's pieces
they're all clustered take on g3 go bishop h4
he's got to try this knight f6 okay he wants
knight h5 maybe c5 and d6 yeah yeah c5 c5 good
move go for it he has to switch night h5 but
now it's too slow you take on g3 black's got to
be winning now look at this game you distract
h
this is not the right way now the king runs to c2
but then he wants queen f2 bishop takes a bishop
b6 very practical as well practical aha no but
queen b-1 is a threat he might be missing queen
b-1 we should be missed 24 24 yeah now this
should be winning queen a-2 and takes b-66
here we go he's taking 94 94. back to d4
take g6 though when when you for queen
you four knight chief bishop at six bishop at
six okay nobody's careful now e4 is a threat
yeah the ship's five now queenie three becomes a
threat no i agree with you but this is unstoppable
this is a huge threat because well knight g5 oh no
actually king d1 he goes look at this stuff just
finished 23. he's just gonna keep it i didn't
like when f2 knight at 6924 yesterday tonight
oh my gosh he forces the queen trade that's huge
and now it's a draw wow can you believe that
this is unbelievable i mean how to survive
this position and actually watch white now
get a better position oh my god if white wins this
that's i will fall out of my chair no i i actually
i'm so winning for black that was so nice oh no
i think these are the moments where gokesh is
lacking where he had to finish him off i think
at least two three games it happened and the
score would be completely different it would have
been like nine for arjun and then eight nine yeah
so this finishing off is so so important hook is
lagged there and i mean of course kudos to arjuna
incredible defender was so so resilient um just
finding every little opportunity it's crazy
um bishop f3 queen e7 queen e7 cd rook d8 no
somebody in the chat is angry
not in the twitch chat in the chat.com chat
yeah yeah sorry queen g4 looked at queen g4
oh one zero and you can't go g6 g6 he still
holds on but then takes a bishop f6 maybe
yeah we should be saying yes okay goku is fighting
back he has to convert such portions he does yeah
good so far now he started well in the last game
two at some point though it starts slipping away
from him threatening bishop f6 nice nice nice
f5 oh bishop f6 what happens after bishop f6
but then f6 again finding two chances but
we should have six no we should be seven
yep nice yeah i think you've got to keep
the bishops i mean trading the bishops
is already some sort of admission failure
yeah yeah okay he does f6 h3 just play yeah
maybe in quincy seven there we go
okay what to do now rook t4 something
general improving move like that
yep he's listening to both yeah but thanks
for watching queen v7 ruxia bishop queen b7
king f7 and then rook d1 okay c2 played a4 a4
right great yeah yeah now queen is tied t7 if
you take on b3 you allow 27 yeah yeah yeah before
white is winning this a5 85 rush yeah bishop b6
amazing you're calling i like that you can predict
everything yeah let's say this should be six oh
queen a6 i thought maybe but
again now it becomes unclear
no queen c4 no quincy what you just taken rook a1
goes here he stops the pawn from behind now if he
takes the pawn black is pressing and this is crazy
okay five and again again not able to
deliver the rugby five and b3 is coming
that rook on d1 is defended he can't even move
the bishop oh no man but he's got to go for it
yeah queen season quincy maybe yeah yeah
queen season yeah rupees 3 quincy 8 quincy it
you know is the water ah quincy too massive
defense now queen f5 no no no no no no queen
c2 coming in yeah it's just the technique you
were absolutely right um but it is just lacking
bishop three king e6 he's gonna start bringing
the king in oh i see that my discord has raided
welcome welcome what does that mean discord like
the people who you don't you know discord right
yeah yeah but what does it mean for discord
to read like all of them who are watching they
just jump in you're like how are you okay well
welcome we've got a great crowd here we've got
still thousands watching this match we appreciate
everybody so engaged we're having a great time and
uh we hope you are as well so big shout out to
everybody uh watching whether it's early or late
um wouldn't be the same without the fans agreed
and this is going to be a draw painful draw for
ghoukesh after getting such a winning portion
yeah he's the one who has to make the draw yeah
but the bishop is anchored you know without the
pawn you can lose that easily yeah yeah yeah
hmm yeah draw and um maintaining
the seven point lead is arjun
now let's see what uh oh bishop g5 look at that f6
here i thought is sort of the critical move really
i thought knight f6 is the move no okay doesn't
that transpose to like a trompowski with d5 yeah
yeah if you play yeah e3 and that's a very that's
a very profound point i just mean there it's the
same like a4 queen b1 b4 isn't it like similar to
that right yeah queen season i really don't like
uh yeah this okay i to just uh what to say
disappoint the fans i would say that the match is
almost over i think there's no coming back for
ghoukesh uh but it's about pride now you know
bishop f5 if you can put up a good show and like
win a couple of games that would be nice and in
addition there's prize money involved because
a percentage of the prize money goes based on
the amount of games that you have won so there's
specific stuff on the line and i you know i don't
want to put words in people's mouths but at least
in my case you never just you play until the last
drop of blood you know you might know that you've
lost the match but you you know as you said it's
about pride and it's about efforts and uh yeah
you know there's still a lot of fun games to go
in the last 20 minutes here so i would ask to chat
if they want to have like ask any questions uh
because we will be interviewing the players after
the match so if they have any questions just put
them in i'm reading so maybe we can ask them some
fun questions definitely we should be five now
94. now he's going to get the blockading square
oh but i thought he should have taken bishop b5
right now there's a possibility of trading
knights potentially either through f6 or three
rookie two yep yeah and look at the time 49
seconds of king f7 there's a3 no bishop v3 doesn't
work whoa okay knight h6 though yeah rookie
six but is it something bishop e3 in the end ah
did this happen in the game it did oh amazing
but maybe ba and then king h6 rookie five
knight c3 try to catch that king somehow but i
don't see how yeah king at six well he did wow
bishop g5 bishop okay he pushes the beast
and he finds that practical chance how do
you stop the fight agreed agreed amazing
very practical now bishop g5 and rupert
what's happening is white winning
why it's winning well there's
some past pawns but rookie eight is
unstoppable yeah but then b3 b4 b3 g7
oh you gotta go
so sharp king but then rook takes d7 king no
he's got to go here in d7 i mean d7 has got
to be winning yeah yeah yeah and then luke g7 rook
f7 gg rookie action you know oh no again again but
g7 unbelievable bishop g7 look at him yeah
yep okay it's getting bad getting bad
yeah rookie jade wins and there is
enough resources there and resignation
we see that rating is not coincidental uh he
is worth probably even more than than that
so experienced it will it's so fast so accurate
so sharp it just turned i think after bishop e3
i thought black was the favorite but yeah
you got this idea with d5 it's incredible
um now how tough it's just it's got to be
tough to play you know when you feel like
you're getting pummeled yeah yeah yeah
yeah you just wanted to be over yeah
just wanted to finish bishop g5 yeah nice
move i think this is actually a lion yeah
yeah but gotta keep keep it
going you know you have to uh
have to try to score some on our goals bishop
okay so now wait a minute there was like queen f2
but d5 was p7 objection nice what if rookie five
no this is probably not good why not you should
find out d1 bishop d5 bishop p5 no no i didn't
want to play bishop d5 i want to play rookie 7.
that would have been really
interesting he's got queen a4 though
okay queen e3 not bad not bad rookies now
they're like slicing through queen d6 might
come knight c6 though oh nice but 26 27
maybe maybe at six has to be played okay
yeah now i think it switches over one
zero one zero with the comeback win
yep do you think he's just freezing no
i think he'll resign after bishop d5
he will he i think he will sign after bishop c6
i think he'll resign maybe
after bishop v7 he will resign
it did there we go finally fifth time is the
charm that was a great game um now come back
as they start the next game we just want to
show one more time the match score progression
um as we see slowly building up that lead um was
arjun of course uh you know bit by bit the word to
describe this consistency as you were saying from
the very start yeah just iron clad boa constructor
chess and so tactically sharp and um he just kept
on i think when it came to this time pressure
moments there was a big big difference there
between right issues play and uh arjun's play
now a question what do you like to ask actually
yeah that's it see i always i'm gonna be wide
open about this i think that's my weak spot of
commentating i'm really like i'm not good at
inventing questions on the fly it's not that i'm
not interested in their thoughts but i never know
what specifically to ask so one thing we could ask
i guess is like it's all the cliche question you
know did you prepare yeah how did you prepare
are you upset are you happy that you won yeah
so maybe the the chat can help us here what
do you think do any questions i want to ask
like he's about to just like after
the match he'll just sleep right there
right he's on that very chair that
looks like a comfortable chair
and i can see that gurkish is upset
on the camera i can sense that
yeah that head in the hands and we see the live
odds five percent now for and i mean that's so
if uh arjun wins who would he play in the next
match uh great question i don't know off the
top of my head let's see if we can get that uh
and we have our amazing producers pulling up
the bracket right there he will play um let's see
the winner of jeffrey jean against uh notre dame
uh i guess jung i guess yeah definitely heavy
heavy favorite is jeffrey but nordenberg is
a good blitz player so it's going to be an
interesting match as well but most likely jean um
okay cool you know yeah but we'll see i see
there is another grand master ronald sadwani
in the chat who's also playing this tournament he
says vd arjun sleeps at four i know him all right
so that was that rumor was uh maybe he's just
that relaxed chill he's just chilling so relax
by the way knight f5 is it winning now knight g8
i think it is look at that knight king to c3 yeah
coming nigerian even 95 both the moves here yep
getting out of here very nicely very nice catch
yeah and now where do you go oh oh double attack
just knight six is the key c6 will be played now
it just resigns yeah why but i don't think it
was resignable oh maybe there was knight g5
right and it's you can get a little tilted that
way you know i actually will admit that when i get
really tilted i tend to do that i start resigning
really really early when i like lose a pawn
you know what i mean you just start resigning i've
never seen your design when i'm very tilted i can
totally do that i'm a late resigner normally i can
be quite obnoxious in my late resignation i admit
but i don't know i i always felt like i feel like
it was not so much of a tilt today it was just
the strength i think arjuna was much stronger
in blitz in my opinion do you feel the same
completely i mean it's just the strength to saw
evidence in every aspect um consistency but also
calculation positional game ci day
every time control it was showing
um so incredible i guess usually in the first
rounds of this tournament uh first like in the
knockout it's usually like the score there's a big
difference but as it gets closer um second round
third round and the finals the scores are much
more balanced i would say like it's a very close
fight right now bishop c5 by the way only moving
oh yeah take that knight out of the picture yeah
yup he does it oh i see another very popular
streamer anna is in the chat shout out
and uh we appreciate so many
awesome people raunak you know
all the fans here to accompany
us is the match draw still clause
queen b2 should be played yeah you know that
up now the queen okay he does this now beef
big foot is asking where is my shoulder okay
bigfoot you yeah we're not gonna give you a shout
out because you're no you have too much power
exactly but white is definitely better i think
toward the end here he's playing well queen b two
had to be played by the way rookier i don't like
yeah but he doesn't need to care now this is like
a seven this is such a nice position 965 even yeah
97. how much time is left 10 minutes on the
dot just a little hair under 10 minutes now
so i guess three or four games would be played
right now yep so let's see if uh lucas can make
it a little bit closer he's got this end
game up upon will he be able to convert
which he has had been having
trouble with the whole match
he says we yeah we gave him a shout out he
timed out two of your mods and i'm so happy
oh this is this is cruel 94 by
the way is interesting 94 a rook
so good oh i would never take on e6 i guess
he wants rookie five yeah but still very very
concrete so did you win like last two games or
what's the deal no no no arjun won the last game
right right right yeah so nice game there and
um yep nine minutes left exactly in the match
it means gambit here bigfoot exposed is going on
oh yeah this is what we all really came for so
so yeah um what is this b5 stuff
i guess he wants a5 quickly
rubio knight is a b b 1 he wants this and then
he wants to attack this pawn maybe i would take
maybe i would take on before first and then
he does that he's going to knight the fight
it's all about seven check
also by the way oh that exists
yeah but we a double attack i mean
you attacked six yeah you know
and we remind g6h4 and we remind the
uh fans here that uh the reason part of
the reason they're completing the match is
because a significant portion of the price
does depend on the actual number of wins even
if the results of the match has been decided
uh which i think is a great touch i mean it's you
know it's fitting to conclude the match um and uh
they're continuing to fight as we can see but h5
oh 95 yeah he's now just playing for the crowd
h5 but i think this is really good it's so
satisfying to win such a game by the way with you
know with such domination and now i would add some
sacrifices to the mix like some bishop gt ideas
which doesn't work obviously but this is arjun he
will play like very consistent knight g4 kind of
moves no he'll play bishop d3 yeah he'll just
almost yep got it whoa look at those squares
i guess now i'm able to guess his moves um i
think he's going to go knight c1 to d3 at some
point or maybe not knight c maybe just takes no
knight c5 bishop d5 oh bishop d5 should be four
look at the mango queen c5 he'll play queen
c5 or bishop c5 if his spawn were on a h7
that would be a little bit better yeah but
still good enough what is it rookie 8 h7o
so the king can get h7
wow i'm just i was just thinking if you could
uh ask them with your grisha accent yeah some
questions afterwards do you think they would they
appreciate it you think i should actually do that
look at arjun i i think he doesn't
care about anything whatever you do
right but it now me of me of course i also
don't really care what anybody does i simply
make decisions based on what i want yes
um yeah watch grishav just he's going to knock
on my door right now like i'm not happy with this
no but i'm a big fan of your christian accent
man i've never seen a grishok accent like this
yeah well okay sometimes it's
basically what i do to pass the time
yeah origin is like 92 yeah sorry sorry you're
seeing something no no nothing nothing of
substance like most of the things i say i guess e4
oh yeah he does play e4 yeah e4 oh the d4 square
is yielded but no it's pondo three points upon in
the opinion of uh international mastermind canyon
only those who watch the entire
stream know that reference exactly no
but it's like such all the
russians know that reference
you'd be sort of old-school russian players but
now everybody's going to know that which is great
and this looks nasty nasty for white there's a
huge demand for anish accent but i think anish's
accent is tough to pull off very he speaks so
fast he speaks so fast that it's very hard to
mimic him it's yeah it's similar to nepo in some
way but uh i promise uh give me a week or so
i'll work on that next i'll give you guys my word
anish accent coming in in one week indeed it's
yeah it's similar to nepo so i don't think it'll
be impossible now d2 by the way is is interesting
if i should g5 or maybe rook c1 roxy one d2 oh
yeah ruxin ruxin d2 seals the deal oh bishop
yeah eight seconds knight c3 will be played
and then uh bishop c3 no okay of course
our pleasure thank you for uh in the chat
designs coming in nice fork 92.
yeah rook d1 with bishop p1 takes in rookie eight
swing it back oh this rook t even more precise
and three and a half minutes to go probably two
games left in this match tough tough for bukesh
now down nine points but he keeps fighting
what to do such is the nature of this game
agreed uh big margin by the way i i
think yesterday nihal won by 16 to eight
right and today what's the score like 16
and a half seven and a half already yeah
right right i mean i honestly i expected
it to be a little bit closer but
i also think um yeah the form uh he
made very few blunders uh did uh arjun
i can't even think of a single like one move
blunder he made so i think the prediction was
seven to three in one plus one by the uh i don't
know what is that called scc prediction meter how
dare you get the name now smart chess statistical
analysis yeah meter analysis is so easy
of course it's rolls right up
just analytical statistical
an analytical database excel spreadsheet analysis
uh platforms i know all of that talk because
i'm from the bay area i know that silicon
valley talk developing engineering platforms
for a better tomorrow the integrating
solutions and seo management enhancement
smart chess prediction software
analysis it was close that's very close
very very nice name guys but a very nice name
very easy to remember this is the most anyone has
ever taught and talked about it in its history
but yeah now again an advantage here
for white look at that pawn on e5
i guess the knight on d5 can
be dislodged with c4 yeah yeah
it's now all about pride right oh
look at these squares these squares look at f4 by
the way can be considered here knight of the 96
yeah also yeah yeah he goes for 96. of the
show i know bishop g5 yeah i know arjuna 98
if rook g7 maybe no no you're going to
should be five he'll be bishop at six
he'll go an idea for the
fans we should read the fans
oh
h4 though you just repeat it that
way i guess it's nick in the chat
oh totally yeah it's gotta
be oh look at these squares
my last day last day today here guys after messing
up that oh you're fired knight g5 takes e6 look at
this knight completing its victory tour knight
d8 takes 66 takes the rook this is a symbolic of
the match and i think that might have been the
last game or they have one more to go one more
seven seconds oh if he had not resigned the game
would be over yeah and this is the last game folks
a 10 point lead yeah so what are we so what are
we asking the players but it's uh pretty close
the smart chess addict analysis prediction it is
very cool yeah it was seven three it could happen
wait so what is the current score in
the bullet though it's six three no
oh my goodness so it's almost on the dot that
actually is really impressive i know we were
laughing about it but that is really impressive
oh people are now writing uh the questions
how sleepy are you guys trish uh it's 1 a.m in
india by the way i when i only struggle with i
don't want to seem like i'm being obnoxious
like i know it can be very upsetting to lose
such a match and i hate to like impinge on his
recovery period you know especially with gucaish
yeah and i feel like sometimes it can be
invasive to ask her oh like what went wrong
bro let me you know let me reflect like you just
recovered yeah yeah none of your business you know
so i struggle with that a little bit so you want
to go for the questions or i should take charge
let's alter i mean maybe i can start
and then we'll alternate yeah about that
so guys in the chat if you have some
questions which you really want to know
yeah we need help you really really want to know
uh some more by the way instead d5 want a piece
there i think oh yeah we should be thinking yeah
whoa
yeah yeah maybe like we are in
sync there rook d7 coming in so
smart chess prediction meter you
might be just wrong by one point there
or not oh no or not or not but uh ef now i
actually have a potential idea from someone
in the chat i remember kramnik hosted this camp
with top indian talents and they played no castle
chess yeah and maybe we could ask them about
their experience playing no castle chess and if
they think it's actually you know worthwhile yeah
you can go ahead with it by the way just again
proving smart because before b3 and now arjuna
i think black's going to win it it's exactly
going to be 739.49 c4 coming in but nine seconds
left yeah amazing yeah don't play rookie five
yeah rookie fight rugby it was also okay rook d4
looking 92 oh no now the knight comes to f5 f5
no no he won't play five g6 you will pretty much
don't know arjun yet yeah it's just i i can't
knight f3 and rook d a would have been interesting
with some mating ideas he like does the second
thing first he wants to trade and then mate him
on f3 oh it's almost mate rookie takes this one
knight d3 such technical play knight
of four check yeah 96 rook d4 knight p2
collects all the pawns and he shuts him back down
yeah now i know arjun how he plays 96 rook a7 but
i don't think he played that particularly well
here i think it was overly technical if anything
but he's explaining he doesn't
need to f4 and mate on f4 go f4
okay now i hope this doesn't last for
another hour okay the match is over guys
the magic all right folks all right guys
all right hey guys it's john all right f4
g3 he's still trying to win yeah yes yeah it's the
well i understand i mean competitive yeah yeah but
whatever guys is it happening oh no i thought g3
was a nice trick there oh and samaha yeah oh g3
wow
please don't play this 400 moves yeah i'm
also solemnly asking these players to remember
that the match is over and yeah
yeah yeah save it for the next match right exactly
all right we have five thousand almost five
thousand people thank you everyone for joining in
and we've only grown that number despite a minor
tournament going on so we appreciate it this has
been amazing we will say our proper thank you uh
at the end if this game ever ends but the thank
you speech yay indeed that's what everyone's
waiting for and there's just going g3 arjun
yeah just go finally thank you takes an f2 but
this is going to last again for another 30 moves
oh you might meet him though how where's
the mate i asked my mother the how i'm
not a specialist in high energy we
should have fun we should have fun
i don't like bishop g2 but again it's fine
yeah draw no king f3 but then bishop f1 yeah okay
my first question is going to be arjun why
you just didn't take the draw there yeah
yeah just take it end the suffering
this is crazy the last game of the
match what the hell is five ditches
i just see oh it's i heard of it there we go
finally seven moves and that concludes
officially the match 18 to eight in favor um
of course of argentina guys the incredible
performance um indeed by him in all sections
across all games and i believe we will take a very
short break before returning with the interviews
um yeah we will break very shortly and when we
come back interviews with our two competitors
so
welcome back ladies and gentlemen and we have
for you um today's two competitors grandmasters
arjun uh arigaisi and uh gucash domingo
uh arjun congratulations on an excellent
match um we felt vivid and i felt
throughout the match that you demonstrated
very very practical play very consistent play
uh did you make some sort of conscious decisions
before the match as to style or did you just kind
of play your usual chess and things went well
i just did my usual check and it worked out
quite well yeah we were impressed throughout it
yeah i noticed that many times you're taking like
practical decisions um so according to you what
do you feel uh was a critical moment and where
did you start feeling comfortable in the match
i think at first i was quite comfortable
but then in three plus one i lost one game
and i was on a slide till but
it didn't really affect me
and what about you uh what did you think went
wrong uh for you in the match it was close
little many games i felt that you had chances
but you couldn't convert where arjuna was very
what say um very resistant so do you think that
was the deciding factor what went wrong for you
yeah i think in the opening you
know i was better in many games but
the last seconds like uh below
10 seconds i was not able to
well fair enough fair enough and uh that was very
well played uh and well fought by you as well well
we will not take up any more of your time we know
it's very late for you and you've just played a
very difficult match congratulations once again uh
arjun on an excellent match and kukesh to you as
well for for a great fight um and thanks uh both
it was a pleasure pleasure to commentate the match
goodbye and well that concludes today's match
vidit what is your hot take um what is sort of the
word that describes today's match in your opinion
i think it was a i i don't think there were like
big blunders or something i think um the match
was played at a pretty high quality for blitz
and i felt like just in the critical moments
as gurkish pointed out that arjun was much more
tougher and uh very sharp in tactics so i think
he deservedly won the match no indeed i i agree
completely well before we conclude let's take one
more look at the bracket of course we know that
arjun has advanced he will play the winner of
jeffrey zhang against norderbeck abdusatorov
of course jeffrey is the favorite that's going
to be a fascinating match and we remind you
that the smart chess prediction which today
was kind of redeemed predicts that nihal sarin
who yesterday scored a convincing victory against
andrew ting will go on and win the whole fake but
of course we have so many close matches to come
this is only the beginning we've already been
treated to some incredible chess and unfortunately
today comes to a close but we have so many more
days of action um did it it was a real privilege
and and uh pleasure to be commentating with you
as we take one quick look at the scheduling we
have a whole month of action thank you so much
uh this was awesome thank you daniel it was great
commentating with you uh looking forward to more
more of this stuff absolutely and uh we want to
send a huge thank you to the thousands of fans
over five thousand on one platform
and throughout platforms who were
staying up late and cheering on the players uh and
participating in a very lively chat this would not
be possible without you so we really appreciate it
uh and with that being said uh thank you everybody
um this was gm daniel there it is he commentating
with jim vida gujarati we hope everybody stays
safe have a great rest of the day and we will
see you during the next match goodbye peace
so
you